haben sie mühselig von paar Tagen jetzt
ins Werk gesetzt die gasumlage hätten
sie schon vor über einem Monat hier
wegräumen können wir haben sie zweimal
im Bundestag hier zur Abstimmung
gestellt haben beantragt dass sie die
gasumlage weghauen das haben sie nicht
getan sondern haben zweimal für ihre
gasumlage gestimmt Herr Harbeck hat uns
in der letzten Woche noch beschimpft
weil wir die Abschaffung der gasumlage
gefordert also ich sage es jetzt mal
ganz ehrlich man kann sie jetzt dazu
beglückwünschen dass sie endlich auf den
richtigen Pfad kommen aber mehr auch
wirklich nicht tut mir leid sie haben
die in der letzten Woche war doch eine
wunderbare Debatte sie haben gesagt die
Gasanlage muss weg aber sie haben nicht
einmal nicht einer ihrer Redner in der
Debatte und ich war ja auch mit dabei
hat einmal gesagt naja dafür müssen wir
eben dann Geld aufnehmen oder hat gesagt
dieses funktionieren soll ich glaube es
ist richtig zu kritisieren das Aufgabe
der Opposition das finde ich absolut
richtig aber Sie müssen natürlich dann
die ganze Geschichte
einführen neben dem Geld fällt ja auf
dass gerade
bei auf der Seite wo das Problem
eigentlich herrscht nämlich auf
Angebotsseite woher kriegen wir die
Energie da passiert reichlich wenig wenn
ich gestern den Bundesfinanzminister und
FDP-Vorsitzende in einer Fernsehsendung
reden höher der sagt wir brauchen
demnächst die fünf Atomkraftwerke am
Netz dann können viele sagen jawohl der
Mann hat natürlich recht aber er setzt
sich ja nicht durch in dieser Ampel wenn
ich sehe dass heute einen Anteil im
Deutschen Bundestag der von der Union
schon mehrfach gestellt auch von der
Ampel durchgewinkt wird nämlich das
Biomasse endlich nicht mehr gedeckelt
wird da muss man doch sagen hat diese
Ampel aus welchen Gründen auch immer an
der energieangebotsseite bisher völlig
versagt das kann ich auf in keiner
Hinsicht so unterschreiben wir haben es
geschafft dass wir auf gas-seite 91% der
Speicher den höchsten Füllstand zu
diesem Zeitpunkt im Jahr bisher
hinbekommen haben das haben wir über
klare Regulierungen geschafft wir haben
es geschafft fsruise in einer
Geschwindigkeit zu an also schwimmende
lng-schiffe in einer Geschwindigkeit ans
Netz anzuschließen dass die wir noch
nicht gesehen haben und wir haben jetzt
diese Woche dafür gesorgt dass immer
mehr kohlek Qualitäten und das ist viel
mehr als die Atomenergie mit ans Netz
gehen wir haben diese Woche gesehen dass
der Wirtschaftsminister zwei weitere
Atomkraftwerke schon mal auf jeden Fall
verlängert und über die weiteren
sprechen wir jetzt wir sind
handlungsfähig und wir haben den ganzen
Sommer den das ganze Jahr über bewiesen
wie schnell wie viele Gesetze wie viele
Dinge wir tun können damit dieses
landkapazitäten hat wir müssen aber
natürlich diese Platte weiterführen muss
ich doch noch mal einen Haken gerade was
die gefüllten Gasspeicher angehen ganz
prima Geschichte die reichen für
zweieinhalb drei Monate da muss noch
irgendwo Energie herkommen aber das Gas
kam vor allen Dingen aus Russland das
wird im nächsten Winter dann nicht mehr
der Fall sein und die FDP guckt zu wie
eben die Atomkraftwerke eigentlich nicht
angeschlossen werden weiterlaufen und
jetzt werden sie im April nächsten
Jahres abgestellt das wird keine Lösung
sein für das kommende Jahr also bisher
gibt es nur den Vorschlag des
Wirtschaftsministers noch kein Gesetz
und ich habe bisher noch nicht gesehen
dass die Bundesregierung beschlossen hat
das nur zwei der Kraftwerke weiterlaufen
wir setzen uns ganz klar dafür ein dass
die weiteren Kernkraftwerke die wir
haben die drei bestehenden auf jeden
Fall weiterlaufen bis 2024 wenn nötig
müssen wir auch weitere Brennstäbe
bestellen weil jetzt brauchen wir jede
Kapazität aber die Aussage dass wir
nichts gemacht haben ist im Gegenteil
genau falsch wir haben jetzt eine Menge
dazu angeschlossen eine Menge dazu
angeregt das weitere Kapazitäten das
Netz kommt Union war massiv daran
beteiligt die Atomkraft in Deutschland
zurückzufahren unter anderem ist die
Union auch daran beteiligt gewesen neben
der SPD natürlich dass wir völlig
einseitig abhängig geworden sind von den
Russen und vom russischen Gas da wäre
natürlich eine Entschuldigung mal
angesagt dennoch das macht es ja nicht
besser die Frage wie die Ampel sich
jetzt verhält auf der Angebotsseite die
ist sicherlich diskutabel also man hätte
die Kohlekraftwerke viel früher
hochfahren müssen Herr Harbeck hat
monatelang gezögert dann hat er
schließlich getan mittlerweile sind zwei
zwei Kohlekraftwerke in Niedersachsen am
Netz im Übrigen noch kein einziges in
Deutschland das ist schon ein Problem
die Kernkraftwerke darüber diskutieren
sie und streiten sie in dieser Ampel
jetzt ich weiß nicht ein halbes Jahr
oder noch länger jedenfalls seit
Ausbruch des Krieges man fragt sich auch
als hätte längst entschieden werden
können die Brennstäbe hätten längst
bestellt sein können und dann wäre klar
dass mindestens in diesem und im
nächsten Winter wir die drei Kraftwerke
die jetzt noch am Netz sind weiter zur
Verfügung haben ich wünsche Ihnen bei
den internen streiten dass sie sich da
durchsetzen Herr Köhler drücke ich Ihnen
wirklich die Daumen aber das jetzt hier
schön zu reden diesen internen Zank das
finde ich ehrlich gesagt nicht in
Ordnung dass sie sagen es sind jetzt
erst seit sechs Monaten sind wir in der
Debatte darüber wie wir die Kohlekraft
Verlängern der 24 September ist nicht so
viel länger her sie sagen also genau das
richtige wir haben es geschafft jetzt
schon eine Menge dafür zu tun aus der
Kohle Reserve übrigens im Gesetz das ja
von ihrer Regierung mitgetragen wurde
und mitkam die Kohle aus der Reserve
rauszuziehen Niedersachsen liegt ja auch
in Deutschland deswegen gibt es auch in
Deutschland jetzt schon Kohlekraftwerke
die am Netz sind und weitere sind gerade
das hat RWE ja gerade angekündigt werden
jetzt an als Kapazitäten ans Netz gehen
dass Energie dass ersatzkraftwerke
bereitstellungsgesetz dass er genau
diese coole regelt ist vor der
Sommerpause durch den Bundestag gegangen
also wenige Monate nach Beginn des
Krieges wir bauen den g-terminals und
Infrastruktur im halben Jahr und das ist
auch die Antwort auf die gasfrage weil
im kommenden Jahr wird kein russisches
Gas mehr fließen aber natürlich werden
wir dann die lng-terminals haben in
großer Zahl wir werden die Infrastruktur
dafür haben deswegen mache ich mir auch
da keine Sorgen dass wir es hinbekommen
im nächsten Jahr weiter Gas
einzuspeichern der Bürger jedenfalls
versteht nicht mehr was im Einzelnen
läuft und an was ist auch immer liegen
mag aber gestern kam die erschreckende
Zahl das 14 Prozent mehr Gas verbraucht
wurde als im vergangenen September das
sind natürlich Zustände es kann so nicht
weitergehen deswegen das zeigt ja auch
dass gerade bei der Angebotsseite viel
viel mehr passieren muss auf der
gasangebotsseite haben sie natürlich
eine riesige Herausforderung weil es
gibt einen Weltmarkt und der hat halt
nur leider eine limitierte Anzahl von
Gasmolekülen zur Verfügung beim Strom
ist das anders beim Strom schaffen über
die Biomasse über die erneuerbaren
Energien über jetzt auch dann die
Kernkraftwerke und vor allen Dingen über
die Kohlekraft das was wir brauchen über
den Winter aber Gas ist physisch knapp
deswegen ist es notwendig dass die
Industrie die hat schon viel gespart und
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger sparen wenn
sie September vergleichen haben sie
recht es ist mehr vergasverbraucht
worden aber es war auch ein drastisch
kälterer September als die anderen
Winter das heißt auch die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger haben glaube ich verstanden
dass sie Gas einsparen müssen aber wenn
es sehr sehr kalt über den Winter wird
dann wird es natürlich dazu führen dass
wir mehr Gas verbrauchen und ich glaube
auch diesen Appell kann man an jeden und
jede Bürgerin rechten Momenten müssen
wir alle was dafür tun dass wir kein
keine gasmangelage bekommen zehn Prozent
Inflation wurde gestern gemeldet und
nächstes Jahr könnte es noch viel
schlimmer aussehen ist es da eigentlich
richtig so viel Geld aufzunehmen von
Seiten des Staates das ist ja jetzt über
den wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds ein
Trick des Finanzministers er belebt ihn
wiederholt Kredite darüber sind die
eigentlich dann Teil des Bundeshaushalts
fürs nächste Jahr nein so wie es geplant
ist sind diese Kredite nicht Teil des
Bundeshaushalts nicht für dieses Jahr
nicht für nächstes Jahr sondern es ist
tatsächlich eine Schattenhaushalt der
neben dem Bundeshaushalt eingerichtet
wird und in dem dann diese bis zu 200
Milliarden geparkt werden sollen man
dann nach und nach über drei Jahre
abfließen lassen will das ist die
Technik das macht die ganze Sache
natürlich sehr sehr Intransparenz das
muss man sagen aber im Kern
will ich auch durchaus zugestehen wir
müssen natürlich was machen um den
Verbrauchern zu helfen aber auch um
unseren Betrieben und Unternehmen zu
helfen also wir müssen jetzt am Ende den
Gaspreis ich sage das mal runter
subventionieren weil die Leute natürlich
nicht in vier fünf sechsfachen Gaspreis
zahlen können das ist nicht zumutbar
also muss was passieren was ich bei
dieser Regierung sehr vermisse ist dass
man mal irgendwie in die Aufgabenkritik
guckt und mal sagt gibt es nicht
irgendeine Stelle an der wir auch was
einsparen können können wir nicht auch
Mittel einsetzen die wir jetzt
zusätzlich zur Verfügung haben diese
Regierung macht im Moment ums klar zu
sagen ein Riesengeschäft mit dieser
großen Endstation weil ja die Preise so
exorbitant gestiegen sind verdienen sie
deutlich mehr über die Umsatzsteuer das
sind pro inflationspunkt etwa 10
Milliarden davon die quasi einfach so
rausgeballert mit ihren
entlastungspaketen per Gießkanne statt
diese Mittel zielgerichtet schon in
diesem Fond geparkt zu haben
ermittelberger sie können nicht mehr
antworten drin geht es nicht los vielen
Dank dass sie da waren und apropos
Umsatzsteuer darum geht es nämlich jetzt
die Bürger werden entlastet obwohl eben
die gasumlage nicht kommt bei der
Umsatzsteuer und alles weitere jetzt im
Plenum
und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich wünsche Ihnen allen einen
schönen guten Morgen die Sitzung ist
eröffnet
ich rufe auf den Tagesordnungspunkt 23
zweite und dritte Beratung des von den
Fraktionen SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und
FDP eingebrachten Gesetzentwurfs zur
temporären Senkung des
Umsatzsteuersatzes auf
Gaslieferung über das Erdgasnetz die
Fraktion der cdu/csu hat den
Entschließungsantrag auf Drucksache
3758 zurückgezogen damit entfällt
folglich auch die hier ursprünglich
vorgesehene namentliche Abstimmung
für die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von
68 Minuten vereinbart
ich eröffne jetzt die Aussprache
und das Wort hat für die Bundesregierung
der Bundesminister der Finanzen
Christian Lindner
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen guten Morgen
wir befinden uns in einem energiekrieg
Knappheiten beim Gas werden zu einer
Waffe gemacht diese Waffe gibt wird
gegen uns eingesetzt gegen unsere
Wirtschaft gegen die Menschen in diesem
Land das Ziel ist klar es soll unser
Wohlstand erschüttert werden es soll
unsere wirtschaftliche Struktur
getroffen werden um am Ende dafür zu
sorgen dass unsere gesellschaftlicher
Zusammenhalt erodiert mit der Absicht
dass die Solidarität dieses Landes
gegenüber der Ukraine endet das ist das
Kalkül von Putin wir senden das klare
Signal aus er wird mit dieser Absicht
scheitern
setzt unsere wirtschaftliche Stärke ein
um die Menschen in diesem Land und
unsere Wirtschaft zu schützen um das zu
bewahren was Menschen sich über
Jahrzehnte aufgebaut haben an
persönlichem aber auch an
gesellschaftlichem Wohlstand unseren
Mittelstand die Industrie all das was
soziale Sicherheit und wirtschaftliche
Stärke in diesem Land ausmacht die
temporäre Senkung auf die Umsatzsteuer
für Gas und im übrigen auch Fernwärme
fügt sich ein in ein Maßnahmepaket dass
die Bundesregierung in den vergangenen
Wochen und auch in dieser Woche am
gestrigen Tag noch einmal präzisiert hat
die Gaspreise steigen und der Staat darf
nicht Profiteur davon sein dass für die
Menschen das Leben teurer wird wir
unternehmen alles
wir unternehmen alles um die Gaspreise
insgesamt zu reduzieren der
Bundeskanzler ist im Ausland unterwegs
um langfristige günstige neue
Lieferquellen zu erschließen wir nutzen
die mit öffentlichen Geld aufgebauten
Gasspeicher jetzt im Winter um ebenfalls
Marktsignale zu senden indem wir auch
wieder ausspeichern wir sorgen für
Energieeffizienz und wir beraten gerade
heute übrigens auf der europäischen
Ebene über andere gemeinsame Maßnahmen
der Gaspreis muss insgesamt runter aber
er wird immer noch so hoch bleiben dass
er für die Menschen und die Wirtschaft
eine Belastung darstellt und deshalb
leistet der Staat seinen Beitrag dadurch
dass er seine Steuerlast auf diesen
Gaspreis reduziert
wir haben
wir haben entschieden auch die Fernwärme
mit einzubeziehen in diesem temporären
diese temporäre Steuersenkung und damit
werden weitere 2,1 Milliarden Euro
Entlastung gesamtstaatlich für die
Laufzeit dieser Maßnahme den Menschen
als Vorteil zu teilen
verehrte anwesende liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen diese Maßnahme heute fügt sich
ein in den von der Bundesregierung
vorgeschlagenen Abwehrschirm gegen
diesen energiekrieg wir mobilisieren 200
Milliarden Euro über die Ertüchtigung
des
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds Zweck
und zielgerichtet für Maßnahmen die im
engen Zusammenhang mit dem energiekrieg
stehen es geht nicht darum allgemeine
Vorhaben so wünschenswert sie auch sein
der Ampelkoalition zu verwirklichen
sondern es geht darum jetzt solidarisch
mit den Menschen in diesem Land zu sein
und unsere wirtschaftliche Stärke zu
mobilisieren um sie
für die Zukunft zu erhalten
damit senden wir
damit senden wir gewissermaßen ein
doppeltes Signal das erste Signal ist an
Putin dass wir uns nicht in unserer
Haltung erschüttern lassen sondern dass
wir eine all-in-strategie wählen um
unser Land zu schützen es ist auch eine
zweite Nachricht sondern Nachricht an
die internationalen Kapitalmärkte wir
stellen eine Abwehrschirm auf um uns zu
schützen hinter diesem Abwehrschirm aber
werden wir weiter auch mit den Regeln
der Schuldenbremse Wirtschaften ein
klares Signal an die Kapitalgeber auf
der Welt an diejenigen die deutsche
Staatsanleihen kaufen der Goldstandard
der Staatsfinanzierung wird weiter
Deutschland sein hinter dem Abwehrschirm
bleiben wir solide und damit ist ein
Signal gesendet dass wir in der
Kontinuität der deutschen
staatsstabilitätspolitik verbleiben
werden
hinter diesen Abwehrschirm schützen wir
nicht nur unsere
Staatsfinanzen in der langfristigen
Kontinuität wir erneuern auch unsere
Energieversorgung und bringen alle
Kapazitäten ans Netz die wir haben Kohle
wir beschleunigen die den Zubau der
erneuerbaren von mir so genannten
freiheitsenergien und wir sind auch
Schritte gegangen um Kernenergie für
diese Krisensituation zu mobilisieren
wir haben zum zum zweiten die
Notwendigkeit unsere Wirtschaft zu
stärken und zu erneuern denn das neue
normalen Niveau der Gaspreise wird höher
sein als das was wir in den vergangenen
Jahren und Jahrzehnten gehabt haben wir
nutzen also jetzt den Abwehrschirm mit
der temporären Subventionierung von
Energie inklusive Senkung von
Umsatzsteuer um dahinter das deutsche
Geschäftsmodell zu erneuern dafür
mobilisieren wir auch im Bundeshaushalt
rekordinvestitionen aber das alleine
wird nicht reichen die Wirtschaft
muss sich ja Erneuern der Beitrag den
die Politik dazu leisten kann ist sie
nicht zusätzlich zu beschweren und zu
fesseln und deshalb gehört zu diesen
Abwehrschirm
und deshalb gehört zu diesen
Abwehrschirm liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen auch das zumindest die
Bundesregierung auf
unverhältnismäßige zusätzliche
Bürokratielasten während der Zeit der
Krise verzichten will wir haben einen
belastungsmoratorium verabredet ich
glaube sinnvoll wäre über den Verzicht
auf zusätzliche Belastung auch die
gegenwärtigen Belastungen und Fässern in
den Blick zu nehmen da gibt es noch
unverändert viel zu tun was uns brennt
bremst alleine beim fuel Switch beim
Wechsel von Energieträgern haben wir
unverändert so viel bürokratische
Fesseln die uns bei der Transformation
Bremsen es wäre ein guter Rat an uns
diese Fesseln zu lösen vielen Dank
Bundesfinanzminister Christian Lindner
hat hier eingeführt temporäre
umsatzsteuersenkung auf Gaslieferung die
wird es nämlich geben obwohl es die
gasumlage nicht gibt es war ja mal ein
jungtim aber jetzt hat die Regierung
gesagt wir entlasten die Bürger auch an
dieser Stelle Matthias Mittelberg jetzt
für Union heute
diskutieren die Absenkung der
Umsatzsteuer auf Gas ist richtig
wir hätten das schon viel früher
diskutieren können denn wir haben das
hier im Hause schon als cdu/csu-fraktion
im Februar beantragt da waren sie damals
noch dagegen
das ist jetzt
dieses Ding ist jetzt dann irgendwie die
Notlösung gewesen weil sie dann
festgestellt haben dass sie mit der
gasumlage die Verbraucher zusätzlich
belasten und dann haben sie sich was
überlegt wie sie diese Belastung durch
eine gewisse Entlastung wieder
ausgleichen können dadurch haben wir
jetzt hier diese Debatte aber immerhin
das ganze beruht auf ihrer
Fehlkonstruktion gasumlage das haben sie
jetzt glücklicherweise erkannt ich will
gar nicht die ganze Geschichte wieder
hervorrufen zweimal haben wir hier die
gasumlage zur Abstimmung gestellt
zweimal haben sie für ihre gasumlage
gestimmt jetzt haben Sie erkannt dass
die gasumlage ja was soll man sagen Mist
ist untauglich ist eine Fehlkonstruktion
ist sie beerdigen heute ihre gasumlage
einen Tag bevor sie morgen in Kraft
getreten wäre und sind es stattdessen zu
der Auffassung gekommen eine
gaspreisbremse einer Entlastung der
Bürger sei sinnvoll dazu allerdings
sagen wir dann tatsächlich herzlichen
Glückwunsch wir hätten uns gewünscht
diese Erkenntnis wer ihnen doch früher
gekommen und zwar deutlich früher
so diese Entlastung der Verbraucher die
heute hier zur Debatte steht ist wichtig
aber eine ein großer Wurf ist dieser
Schritt nun tatsächlich nicht der
Bundeskanzler nee ich also es ist so wie
es ist die Gaspreise der Bundeskanzler
hat doch hier vorgerechnet es wäre jetzt
eine ganz tolle Entlastung und das ist
natürlich völliger Käse weil die Leute
sind jetzt mit dem drei vier fünffachen
Gaspreis konfrontiert und wenn sie
vorher eine Gasrechnung hatten mit 1000
Euro und haben darauf 19% Mehrwertsteuer
gezahlt dann mussten sie 190 Euro
Mehrwertsteuer zahlen wenn sie jetzt die
drei Mal so hohe Gasrechnung von 3000
Euro haben dann zahlen Sie zwar nur
sieben Prozent das sind dann aber 210
Euro Mehrwertsteuer das heißt die Zahlen
am Ende sogar mehr Mehrwertsteuer und
das ist ja ihr Problem dass sie
permanent nicht verstehen dass sie an
dieser irren Inflation die stattfindet
an dieser wahnsinnigen Inflation die
stattfindet haben sie doch
massive Mehreinnahmen das müssten Sie
dem Bürger mal ehrlich sagen also in
vielen Bereichen brauchen Sie gar keine
Schulden machen sondern sie müssen nur
intelligent mit den Mehreinnahmen
umgehen und die nicht ständig in
Gießkannen Programmen verpassen
so
und jetzt kommen wir mal jetzt kommen
wir mal zum eigentlichen Kern sie haben
da jetzt ja ein ganz tolles
sechsseitiges Papier vorgelegt der eine
sagt Abwehrschirm der andere sagt
doppelwumms da müssen sie sich jetzt
noch einigen über die Terminologie in
erster Linie in erster Linie ist dieses
Papier zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt nichts
anderes als ein schuldenwumms das sage
ich Ihnen mal ganz deutlich wir haben
200 Milliarden neue Schulden die Sie ins
Schaufenster gestellt haben was sie aber
damit finanzieren wollen ist völlig
unklar es gibt auch gar keine
Kalkulation oder irgendeine
Berechnungsgrundlage die nachvollziehbar
wäre
in den entscheidenden Punkten in den
entscheidenden Punkten
gaspreisbremse ich meine immerhin haben
sie das jetzt erkannt dass sie eine
Preisbremse brauchen und keine Umlage
dazu noch mal herzlichen Glückwunsch
nach vielen Wochen und Monaten aber
wie sie jetzt diese gaspreisumlage
umgestalten wollen konkret da steht doch
nichts in ihrem Papier wie die
strompreisbremse aussehen soll da steht
nichts in ihrem Papier wie sie jetzt
konkret Betriebe und Unternehmen stützen
wollen in der Krise wie viel Geld die zu
erwarten haben wie viel preisentlastung
dazu steht nichts in ihrem Papier das
ist leider die Wirklichkeit dann führe
ich eben mit ihrem Kollegen von der FDP
draußen in Interview der dann noch sagt
die Kernkraftwerke müssen weiterlaufen
alles klar aber dazu steht nichts in
ihrem Papier wir sie haben gestern um
das noch mal klar zu sagen nichts
anderes als 200 Milliarden schulden-
präsentiert wir warten jetzt aber immer
noch auf den Wumms der dann irgendwann
kommt wo sie konkret sagen welche
Maßnahmen sie damit finanzieren und
umsetzen wollen und wie sie die Bürger
in diesem Land entlasten wollen das weiß
bis zur Stunde keine Socke das ist die
Wirklichkeit sie haben Fehler über
Fehler gemacht bisher in dieser Krise
und das ist wirklich traurig genug
das muss man einfach mal in Erinnerung
rufen sie haben den ganzen Sommer über
verdaddelt mit ihren internen
Streitereien jetzt verweisen sie auf
ihre Expertenkommission ja die hätten
doch schon längst fertig sein können mit
der Arbeit die hätten sie schon vor
Wochen einsetzen können dann hätten wir
die konkreten Vorschläge auf dem Tisch
und die richtige Reihenfolge wird auch
gewesen sie hätten die Experten arbeiten
lassen die machen Vorschläge und dann
unterhalten wir uns darüber was die
Vorschläge Kosten jetzt sind sie doch
panisch den anderen wie ich gegangen
weil sie gesehen haben oh Gott da kommt
jetzt die gasumlage diesen Blödsinn den
wir beschlossen haben der tritt morgen
in Kraft und deswegen müssen wir in
dieser Woche ganz schnell panisch noch
einen anderen Finanzierungsweg aufzeigen
deswegen sind sie doch in diese Panik
verfallen in dieser Woche diese
Pressekonferenz zu machen wo sie nichts
Konkretes mitteilen außer dass sie 200
Milliarden Schulden machen diese Aktion
hätte komplett anders rumlaufen müssen
sie hätten jetzt ganz konkret sagen
müssen was brauchen Sie gaspreisbremse
was machen Sie konkret mit der
strompreisbremse wie fördern sie die
Unternehmen in Deutschland wie machen
sie wirklich diesen Abwehrschirm konkret
und dann hätten sie sagen müssen wie
kriegen wir jetzt ganz zügig mehr
Kohlekraftwerke ans Netz um das Angebot
zu vergrößern was machen wir ganz
konkret mit den Kernkraftwerken und da
sage ich Ihnen auch
das ist naiv und unverantwortlich gerade
was die Grünen in Niedersachsen machen
das sage ich Ihnen mal ganz deutlich wir
sind in der größten Energiekrise Europas
seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg in dieser
Situation darf man überhaupt nicht auf
die Idee kommen auch nur irgendein
Kraftwerk abzuschalten und zwar völlig
egal wie es Betrieben ist ob mit Kohle
mit Kernkraft spielt überhaupt gar keine
Rolle sie dürfen jetzt kein einziges
Kraftwerk abschalten das ist die
Wirklichkeit
der nächste der nächste Winter wird
schon heftig genug der übernächste wird
wahrscheinlich noch heftiger werden weil
wir da nämlich nicht volle Speicher
haben die wir noch mit russischem Gas
voll füllen konnten und deswegen ist es
noch unverantwortlicher wenn sie jetzt
Kraftwerke abstellen wollen wir warten
immer noch auf Ihre konkreten Vorschläge
wie sie das Problem lösen wollen bisher
ist nur schuldenwumms und keine
konkreten Vorschläge
Matthias Mittelberg stellvertretender
Fraktionsvorsitzender der Union es ist
bisher nur Schulden Wumms hat er gesagt
und er selber muss man noch dazu sagen
kommt aus Niedersachsen und in der Tat
diese niedersächsische Landtagswahl
spielt ja bei der ein oder anderen
Überlegung sicherlich auch immer noch
eine Hauptrolle Tim küssendorf jetzt
Finanzausschuss mit die SPD
lieber dr Mittelberg ich hatte es schon
in der letzten Sitzungswoche gesagt dass
ich mich eigentlich immer freue in der
Debatte auf ihre Vorschläge einzugehen
und ich kann mich nur wiederholen auch
in dieser Debatte habe ich keinen
einzigen Vorschlag vor ihnen gehört wie
sie das besser machen würden
sie haben uns insgesamt drei
Vorwürfe gemacht der erste Vorwürfe ist
wir handeln zu langsam in Anbetracht
dessen was ich von ihrer Fraktion in
diesem gesamten Jahr an Vorschlägen
gehört hat kann ich nur sagen hätten wir
all dem zugestimmt dann wäre diese
Haushalt nicht nur mehrfach überzeichnet
sondern die Maßnahmen würden sich alle
auch noch widersprechen wir können
dankbar sein dass wir unserem
strategischen gut organisierten Weg
gefolgt sind und nicht ihren Vorschlägen
und einer ein weiterer Punkt der Vorwurf
dass wir zu langsam sind entbehrt doch
jeglicher Grundlage wir haben in diesem
Jahr bereits wenn ich das jetzt noch als
weiteres entlassungspaket dazu zähle was
gestern vereinbart worden ist haben wir
das vierte entlassungspaket
verabschiedet wir sind insgesamt
mittlerweile bei fast 300 Milliarden
Euro ich weiß nicht von welcher
Regierung sie mehr verlangen würden wir
handeln entschlossen schlagkräftig und
schnell und wir tun was für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in diesem Land
und das entkräftet nämlich genauso auch
den Vorwurf dass das kein großer Wurf
sei ich erinnere mich noch gut wo wir im
Februar hier standen oder Bundeskanzler
das Sondervermögen in Höhe von 100
Milliarden Euro für die Bundeswehr
verkündet hat bei ihnen war hier
Volksfeststimmung bei 200 Milliarden
Euro für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger für
die Unternehmen ist das kein großer Wurf
ich weiß nicht in welchen Dimensionen
sie denken das ist deutlich ein großer
Wurf und eine wirksame Entlastung
und zum letzten Punkt wir benennen keine
Details ohne jetzt noch mal auf die
Kommission hinzuweisen oder ähnliches
ich erinnere mich nur an ihren Vorschlag
zu Inflationsausgleich zu dem Antrag der
wurde in der Anhörung zerrissen und wir
wissen alle wie Anhörung funktionieren
und wieder Experten eingeladen werden
der wurde unisono zerrissen alle ihre
Vorschläge haben weder Details noch
Inhalte bitte vertrauen Sie dieser
Bundesregierung sie handelt gut und
richtig schnell und schlagkräftig
jetzt habe ich leider nur noch die
Hälfte meiner Redezeit übrig ich wollte
eigentlich so viel sagen noch zu
Mehrwertsteuersenkung
grundsätzlich freue ich mich wirklich
und das meine ich jetzt ganz ernst dass
die Entlastung auch über die
Mehrwertsteuer noch weiterhin Bestand
hat denn natürlich mit dem abwehrstimmen
den wir gestern vereinbart haben in der
großkoalition in der apfelkoalition
haben wir eine ganze Reihe von Maßnahmen
vereinbart aber vor allen Dingen unter
Punkt 6 auch weiterhin die
Mehrwertsteuersenkung die
Mehrwertsteuersenkung entlastet die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger direkt und vor
allen Dingen schon ab dem 1 Oktober das
ein ganz wichtiger Punkt weil die
Heizperiode jetzt beginnt und die
wirksame Entlastung jetzt schon Eintritt
und ich
und ich freue mich auch dass es uns im
parlamentarischen Verfahren gelungen ist
der Bundesfinanzminister hat es gesagt
dass wir auch die Fernwärme dazu
ergänzen konnten denn gerade in
Ostdeutschland gibt es einfach eine
ganze Menge von Haushalten die über
Fernwärme beheizt werden ich denke da
zum Beispiel an Städte wie Zwickau wo
über die Hälfte aller Haushalte über
Fernwärme beheizt werden und ich glaube
auch diese zusätzlichen 2,1 Milliarden
Euro sind noch mal ein ganz wichtiger
Schritt zu Entlastung
insgesamt sind das also rund 13
Milliarden Euro Entlastung über die
Senkung der Umsatzsteuer die die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger direkt erreichen
und die zusätzlich zum abwehrstimmen
Wirken ich glaube insgesamt ist das
wirklich ein gutes ein gutes Gesetz was
nicht nur ab 1 Oktober gilt sondern was
auch ein Umfang hat von dem man wirklich
sprechen kann dass es ein großer Wurf
ist und ein weiterer Punkt ist ja auch
in diesem Gesetz ja noch untergebracht
worden deswegen möchte ich ihn gerne
noch erwähnen und zwar ist das die
Steuerbefreiung für die
inflationsausgleichsprämie und wir haben
ja viel darüber gesprochen dass
Arbeitgeberinnen und Arbeitgeber
möglicherweise auch nicht in der Lage
sind im Moment diese ausgleichsprämie zu
bezahlen da möchte ich ganz gerne noch
mal einen Artikel zitieren den ich vor
zwei Tagen glaube ich gelesen habe die
deutschen Dax-Konzerne haben ihre
Vorstandsgehälter im letzten Jahr um 25%
erhöht das Argument dass die Unternehmen
in Deutschland nicht in der Lage sind
eine inflationsausgleichsprämie zu
zahlen die wir heute Steuer befreit
machen zählt für mich nicht wer in der
Lage ist Vorstände mit 25% euch zu
bezahlen der muss auch in der Lage sein
für die breite Belegschaft inflations-
gesamt sprechen wir also hier von einer
ja von der AFD ist die letzte Fraktion
von der ich Vorschläge brauche also
vielen Dank Herr Gottschalk
gesamt sprechen wir hier also von einem
Gesetzespaket was auf der einen Seite
die umsatzsteuersenkung hat auf der
anderen Seite die Steuerbefreiung für
die Einmalzahlung es sich einfügt in
einen Abwehrschirm der gestern
vereinbart worden ist ich kann mich nur
wiederholen diese Regierung löst ihr
Versprechen ein wir haben versprochen
wir lassen niemanden in diesem Land
allein und das lösen wir hier mit ein
vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit
Tim küssendorf von der SPD aber seine
Äußerungen strategisch gut organisierter
Weg den wir gefolgt sind da mussten
selbst viele Ampel Koalitionäre Lächeln
Klaus Söder jetzt für die AFD erst
Mitglied im Finanzausschuss
ja sehr geile frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kollegen liebe Gäste auf der
Tribüne lassen Sie mich auch noch mal
kurz auf dem Verfahrensweg dieses
Gesetzes eingehen also ich habe ja
durchaus Verständnis dafür dass regieren
im Moment nicht gerade einfach ist aber
es hat sich auch keiner gezwungen dieses
Amt anzunehmen
anstatt den letzten drei Jahren ein
rot-grünes ideologieprojekt umzusetzen
müssen sich mit der größten
Wirtschaftskrise der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik befassen und man muss
feststellen sind damit total überfordert
sie bringen
sie bringen während der
finanzausschusssitzung ein
Änderungsantrag ein den keiner kennt sie
setzen drei Stunden nach der Sitzung
eine Sondersitzung ein weil ihn
plötzlich einfällt dass sie die
Fernwärme vergessen haben das ist auch
unprofessionell und damit zeigen Sie
auch dass Sie auf die Sachverständigen
Anhörung überhaupt nicht gehört haben
denn dort war dieser Punkt explizit
angesprochen sie hätten also genug Zeit
gehabt bis Mittwoch 10 Uhr diesen Punkt
einzuarbeiten haben sie nicht gemacht
das zeigt auch dass sie die Anhörung für
sie ein reiner Alibi-Veranstaltung sind
das finde ich echt traurig für
Demokratie
und das im Gesetzentwurf die Laufzeit
der umsatzsteuersenkung immer noch an
die gasumlage knüpft ist die ja nun
wahrscheinlich oder höchstwahrscheinlich
wegfällt ist nicht nur ein
handwerklicher Fehler trotzdem stimmen
wir diesen Gesetzentwurf zu weil ein
erster Schritt ist und zumindest die
Privathaushalte Kommunen Krankenhäuser
und so weiter von den hohen Gaskosten zu
entlasten auch der inflationspauschale
von 3000 Euro stimmen wir zu und Herr
Kollege klüsendorf dass sie sich als
SPD-Mitglied an den DAX-Konzern
orientieren das finde ich schon
erstaunlich ne ich Frage nämlich ist ob
alle Unternehmen insbesondere die
kleinen Unternehmen in der Lage sind
diese pauschalen zu zahlen da habe ich
sehr viele jetzt inzwischen angerufen
und sagt was beschließen wir da wir
werden natürlich von Spritkosten und
Energiekosten geplagt oder Arbeitnehmer
sehr schnell ihre chefsfragen wann
bekomme ich denn diese 3000 Euro
ausgezahlt und der Kleinunternehmer wird
sagen ja weil ich dir keine Zahlen kann
aber leider gerade zwei große Strom am
Gasrechnung bei mir auf dem Schreibtisch
liegen und kann dir das im Moment nicht
auszahlen und das geht
spielen so das hat sehr viel Frust
auslösen und wir können eigentlich nur
hoffen dass bis Ende 2024 jeder diese
Pauschale erhalten hat
und da sind wir bei den Unternehmen
insbesondere bei den KMU die bereits
seit Anfang des Jahres durch die hohen
Spritpreise und nur durch die
exorbitanten Energie und Gaspreise
belastet sind den hilft ihre
umsatzsteuersenkung überhaupt nicht und
je nachdem wie Energie und
inkassintensiv dieses Unternehmen sind
stehen inzwischen viele vor dem Aus in
meinen Wahlkreis müssen heute am 30
September drei Bäckereien alles
Familienbetriebe schließen in kahler und
Triptis geht eine mehr als 55-Jährige
Tradition der Porzellanindustrie in
Thüringen am Ende des Jahres zu Ende was
haben sie mit dieser Unternehmen für
Hilfsangebote ihr 200 Milliarden-Paket
da bin ich sehr gespannt kommen wir
zurück zum Carsten Strompreis sie
bekämpfen mit ihren teuren
entlastungspaketen nur die Symptome aber
nicht die Ursachen
zu diesen Ursachen gehört eben auch ihre
total verkorkste Energiepolitik es ist
eben ein und Dingen anzunehmen man
können deinen industriestand wie
Deutschland ausschließlich mit Windkraft
und Solar am Leben erhalten
während weltweit neue moderne
Atomkraftwerke gebaut werden wollen sie
letzten HKW in Deutschland abschalten
dabei der Chef des TÜV ausdrücklich
festgestellt dass wohl die aktuelle
laufenden AKW bei der betrieben werden
können als auch mit relativ kurzer
Anlaufzeit die letzten Jahr
abgeschalteten AKW wie ganz nett gehen
könnten aber ihm geht grüne Ethologie
vor Vernunft und vor allem gegen die
Interessen des deutschen Volkes das ist
auf das ist auf die Regierung gezogen
sie können uns ruhig sein das ist auf
die Regierung bezogen ein profiose
amtseides
wir müssen hier auch über Russland und
Sanktionen sprechen es macht wirklich
extrem für ein schroti der leider heute
nicht da ist er hat mich als Fünfte
Kolonne und zukünftigen Pressesprecher
von Putin tituliert eins will ich mal
klarstellen ja Kollege klüsendorf
die nicht als Demokraten und hier
Vorurteile auch den Angriff auf die
Ukraine als völkerrechtswidrig aber
welcher Krieg ist der nicht
völkerrechtswidrig etwa der Krieg der
USA ein Vietnam oder der Angriff auf die
Irak war das völkerrechtswidrig ich
denke schon wenn wir selber Einstufungen
vornehmen
damit auch für alle
ich war am Sonntag auf einer
Veranstaltung in der Kirche von Rodheim
und mein Heimatort hat das super intent
der evangelischen Kirche in Eisenach
gesagt es gibt keine gerechten es gibt
keine ungerechten Kriege bei Kriege
bedeuten immer nur tot und Zerstörungen
und dem schließe ich mich hundertprozent
an was bringen diese Sanktionen seriöse
Wirtschaftsinstitute gehen davon aus
dass das Bruttoinlandsprodukt in
Russland in diesem Jahr fünf bis acht
Prozent zurückgeht das ist nicht
wesentlich mehr als das der Einbruch im
Corona Jahr 2020 in Deutschland und wo
wir so wie wir Corona 2020 überstanden
haben so steht auch Russland dieses
Sanktionen übrigens gehen die gleichen
Wirtschaftsinstitute inzwischen davon
aus dass wir im nächsten Jahr ein
Rückgang von 7,9 Prozent zu verkraften
haben 7,9 Prozent da kann ich nur sagen
herzlichen Glückwunsch und die Ampel
und ja auf die Auswirkungen auf die
einheimischen Firmen durch die
russlandsaktionen gehen sie überhaupt
nicht ein ich kenne sehr viele Firmen
gerade hier bei uns in Ostdeutschland
die sehr enge wirtschaftsbeziehung
sowohl den Ukraine als auch nach
Russland haben und die stehen im Moment
vor leeren Kassen ja weil sie aufgrund
des Krieges nicht ein Ukrain exportieren
können und aufgrund der Sanktionen auch
nicht nach Russland exportieren können
das ist aber von ihnen vollkommen
ausgeblendet
und über die sogar Sabotage weil
Nordstemmen freuen sich bestimmt einige
Abgeordnete hier im Saal aber vor allen
Dingen die USA welche unsere bisher
guten Wirtschaftsbeziehungen zu Russland
immer schon ein Dorn im Auge waren aber
nun geht es keine Alternative mehr wir
müssen das teure Flüssigkeit aus den USA
und anderswo einkaufen und Kanzler
Scholz und Mister Habeck bei den Star
kannst doch Scholz und Österreich
[Applaus]
das muss man sich echt mal auf der Zunge
zu gehen lassen wir brechen die
Beziehung zum Diktator Putin ab und
lassen uns von einer Diktatur mit
Flüssigkeit und Öl beliefern Team gar
nicht was Menschenrechte sind Frauen
dürfen ohne Zustimmung ihres Mannes
überhaupt gar nichts machen Frauen unter
25 dürfen nicht aus ihren Haus ausziehen
ohne Zustimmung ihres Mannes frauen
dürfen Uni oder Zustimmung ihres Mannes
keine Reisen antreten wer eine Frau die
eine Vergewaltigung anzeigt riskiert
eine Gefängnisstrafe
homosexualität wird ja hier so
propagiert seine Straftat wird mit 100
patchen heben und bis zu sieben Jahren
Gefängnis bestraft und die rund 300.000
Kataris
[Musik]
das hat was damit zu tun sie kaufen der
Geld sie kaufen ja jetzt Gas ein von
Ländern die hier nicht demokratisch
stellen das müssen sich mal anhören ja
und die Krauthausen cataris Beuten 3
Millionen Gastarbeiter aus wann und
diese ist Sklaven das ist nicht mein
Speck das ist nicht meine Information
das kannst Du nachlesen vor der Woche
Sendung Kontraste und das sind nun
unsere neuen Handelspartner von denen
Minister Habeck ein Bückling macht
schämen sie sich für seine Schande für
die deutsche Außenpolitik
kommen Sie bitte zum Schluss
möchte zum Schluss noch ein Wort sagen
kriegt ihr einen Kollegen März sie
hatten sich ja so intensiv mit den
Tumult und das Demonstrationen
auseinandergesetzt und diese denunziert
ich kann Ihnen eines sagen das sind
keine AFD Leute die dort rumlaufen in
ganz normale Bürger auch tu Mitglieder
ganz viele kommen Sie mal nach Eisenach
wir werden Sie keine AFD fahren sehen
einfach nur Burger die die Schnauze voll
haben von ihrer Politik vielen Dank
die Mehrwertsteuer auf Gaslieferung soll
gesenkt werden auf
7%, also dort eine Entlastung für die
Bürger obwohl es die gasumlage nicht
mehr gibt ursprünglich war das ja mal
ein jungtim aber die Bundesregierung hat
sich entschieden diese Senkung
durchzuführen darüber diskutiert der
Bundestag und jetzt Katharina Beck die
finanzpolitische sprech an der
bündnisgründen Kollegen liebe
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zur CDU nur erst
uns von Putins Gas abhängig machen dann
unfassbar viel fordern und überhaupt
nicht sagen wie das finanziert werden
soll das ist unseriös zum Thema die
Gaspreise und die Energiekosten müssen
jetzt sinken 40% der Menschen in
Deutschland haben keine Rücklagen 33
Millionen Menschen in Deutschland haben
also keinen Puffer jetzt hunderte von
Euro mehr kosten zu stemmen diese krasse
energiepreiskrise trifft Menschen mit
niedrigen und mittleren Einkommen
deutlich härter als andere und das ist
wichtig immer vor Augen zu haben
die ca 13 Milliarden schwere befristete
Mehrwertsteuersenkung auf Gas- und
Fernwärme kann einen Beitrag zur
Entlastung leisten bei vollständiger
Weitergabe an die endverbraucherinnen
würden die Preise um circa zehn Prozent
gedämpft das ist gut aber die
Preisentwicklung ist viel extremer die
Verbraucherpreise beim Gas sind im
September außerordentliche 230 Prozent
gestiegen dramatisch vor allem für die
vielen ohne Rücklagen und daher ist es
so gut dass die Mehrwertsteuersenkung
Teil eines größeren Konzepts ist nach
bisher 95 Milliarden in drei
entlastungspaketen hat die Regierung
gestern ein 200 Milliarden Euro schweren
Abwehrschirm vorgeschlagen mit dem der
Gas- und stromkreiskrise auf der
Angebotsseite das ist so wichtig mit nie
dagewesenen preisbremsen begegnet werden
soll
neben dem herausragenden Kraftakt den
herausragenden Kraftakt die Gasspeicher
trotz Putin zu füllen nun ein weiterer
entscheidender Schritt dieser Ampel und
es ist sehr gut dass bei der
strompreisbremse klar nur ein
basisverbrauch und zwar für kleinere
mittlere Einkommen keinem
usubventioniert werden soll und bei der
gasbremse ähnliches vorgesehen ist und
auch das zufallsgewinne der
Stromproduzenten bei der
strompreisbremse zur Finanzierung
herangezogen werden das ist ein sehr
guter Mechanismus der breiten
Finanzierung und wir drücken dem
Wirtschaftsminister die Daumen der in
diesen Momenten beim eu-energieminister
Treffen verhandelt dass eine
funktionierende Abschöpfung der
übergewinne auf der fossilen Energien
beschlossen wird
der Energien die diese Preiskrise
überhaupt erst ausgelöst haben
diese übergewinne werden unter anderem
auch auf dem Rücken der Autofahrerinnen
und Autofahrer erhoben die nach wie vor
fast 50 Prozent an zusätzlicher
Gewinnmarge mehr zahlen müssen als
früher und zwar nur wegen der Marktmacht
die wir nun auch endlich mit dem
Kartellrecht angehen werden
nochmal zur Umsatzsteuer der
Gasverbrauch in Deutschland erfolgt zu
zwei Dritteln durch die Wirtschaft und
die Mehrwertsteuersenkung auf den
Gaspreis kommt bei denen unter den
Preisen bleibenden kleinst- und
Kleinunternehmen bei den Selbstständigen
und Mittelstand leider nicht an denn die
Mehrwertsteuer ist für sie ein
durchlaufender Posten und auch deswegen
ist es so wichtig dass die Finanzierung
für das Energiekosten dämpfungsprogramm
und für die Hilfen für kleinere und
mittlere Unternehmen nun durch den
Abwehrschirm gesichert ist hier wollen
und werden wir nun sehr schnell ins
Handeln kommen wir haben im Bundestag
mit dafür gesorgt dass für die
VerbraucherInnen Fernwärme auch
begünstigt besteuert wird rund sechs
Millionen Haushalte werden in
Deutschland mit Fernwärme geheizt der
Großteil Mietwohnungen und gerade die
ist wichtig zu entlasten trotzdem muss
man objektiv sagen
umsatzsteuersenkungen sind weder
ökonomisch noch sozial die besten
Instrumente zu entlasten dass sie an die
VerbraucherInnen weitergegeben wird das
kann der Staat leider nicht garantieren
und außerdem entlastet man die die viel
verbrauchen und tendenziell mehr Geld
bleiben mehr als die die wenig
verbrauchen und tendenziell weniger Geld
haben trotzdem ist das Gesamtpaket sehr
sehr gut und auch wenn es nach einem
solch großen Betrag gestern seltsam
klingen mag ich muss leider warnen dass
wir weiter schauen ob wir die vielen
Millionen Menschen die überhaupt keine
Rücklagen haben ausreichend unterstützen
sie brauchen es am meisten da müssen wir
weiter darauf achten ich freue mich auf
die weitere sehr gute konstruktive
Zusammenarbeit mit meinen
ampelpartner:innen und meiner Fraktion
vielen Dank
von den bündnisgrün war dass sie es auch
stellvertretende Vorsitzende das
Finanzausschusses nächster Redner
Christian leyhe für die
Linksfraktion spricht der ist der
wirtschaftspolitische Sprecher
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren was ein Chaos zuerst
lassen Sie sich ein Gesetz von den
Energiekonzernen schreiben damit die
Bürger für deren Ausfälle mit der
gasumlage Blechen sollen dann wollen sie
die Umsatzsteuer auf die gasumlage
weglassen damit ihn niemand vorwerfen
kann der Staat verdient daran auch noch
dann muss ihnen die EU sagen das dürfen
sie gar nicht also beschließen sie eine
umsatzsteuerreduzierung für alles Gas
und verkaufen das als in großen
Ausgleich zur gasumlage verschweigen
aber das ein Drittel der Haushalte
trotzdem draufzahlen muss dann machen
sie das ganze auch noch so schlecht dass
gar nicht alle Gaskunden betroffen sind
und dann erwarten sie dass die Konzerne
die Steuersenkung eins zu eins
weitergeben obwohl wir doch beim
Tankdeckel gelernt haben dass das nicht
funktionieren tut wenn es um viel Geld
geht bei Konzernen und dann nur zwei
Tage vor der Einführung der gasumlage
fällt der Groschen und sie Anliegen
diese Schnapsidee endlich meine Damen
und Herren
es ist gut dass die
Mehrwertsteuersenkung die Menschen
entlastet und es ist gut dass sie auch
auf Druck aus meiner Fraktion
aufgenommen haben das Fernwärme
dazugehört aber wegen diesem Chaos und
wegen den handwerklichen Schnitzern
werden wir uns heute enthalten müssen
und halten wir fest in der schlimmsten
Energiekrise der Bundesrepublik spielt
die ampelregierung absoluten
kreisliga-fußball und die Hälfte der
Mannschaft weiß nicht mal auf welches
Tor sie schießen soll man Damen und
Herren
wir haben hier den gaspreisdeckel
gefordert sie haben geschimpft jetzt
übernehmen sie die Idee wir haben hier
eine übergewinnsteuer gefordert sie
haben geschimpft jetzt übernehmen sie
die Idee zum Teil und nennen es eine
strompreisbremse wir haben hier eine
staatliche Preiskontrolle gefordert und
wie sie geschimpft haben und ich
prognostiziere Ihnen Sie werden eine
Preiskontrolle einführen müssen bei
einem gaspreisdeckel oder wollen Sie den
Energiekonzernen einfach so die
Milliarden überweisen ohne zu gucken ob
das eine Richtigkeit hat und wo wir
gerade dabei sind wir haben gegen die
Schuldenbremse geredet sie haben dagegen
gehalten und heute ist die
Schuldenbremse faktisch tot sie ist tot
sie ist beerdigt die Trauergäste sind
auf dem Weg nach auch nach Hause nur
Christian Lindner steht noch an ihrem
Grabe und versucht sich mit ihr für 2023
zu verabreden tragisch ist dass Herr
Lindner nehmen sie Abschied
so und auch wenn Sie unsere Konzepte
teilweise übernehmen die Wahrheit ist
doch Winter ist coming und sie haben
keine vernünftige Strategie für die
kalte Jahreszeit und warum nicht noch im
Juni erklärte Minister Habig eine
Deckelung der Preise wäre bei einem
knappen Gut ein Signal Energie ist nicht
wertvoll Haut raus was ihr wollt heißt
übersetzt sie wollten die hohen Preise
damit die Menschen sich die Heizung
nicht leisten können damit sie Gas
sparen weil nicht genug Gas da ist heißt
aber im Umkehrschluss wenn sie jetzt
ihre Strategie ändern wenn Sie den
gaspreisdeckel vernünftig machen steht
die Frage im Raum haben wir in diesen
Wirtschaftskrieg eigentlich genug Gas
für alle werden wir im Winter genug Gas
für alle haben ja oder nein und deswegen
hoffen Sie auch auf einen warmen Winter
in Deutschland und sie hoffen auf einen
warmen Winter in Norwegen die größte
Volkswirtschaft Europas hofft auf eine
gute Wetterprognose damit hier nicht das
Licht ausgeht und damit hier nicht
tausende Menschen Arbeitsplätze
verlieren ich sage Ihnen etwas was da
draußen alle Menschen schon wissen dass
hoffen auf eine gute Wetterprognose
ersetzt keine Strategie in Energiekrise
und ich sage Ihnen noch was
dieser Wirtschaftskrieg geht für die
eigene Bevölkerung immer mehr nach
hinten los und ich kenne da draußen
außerhalb der politikblase nicht einen
Menschen buchstäblich nicht einen
einzigen Menschen der nicht weiß dass
der russische Überfall auf die Ukraine
der Wirtschaftskrieg und die aktuelle
Energiekrise zusammengehören alle
Menschen wissen das sie werden über die
Sanktionen reden müssen sie halten das
in diesem winterpolitisch nicht durch
das fliegt ihnen um die Ohren und
deswegen komme ich zum Schluss diese
Gesellschaft braucht Heizung Brot und
Frieden Heizung Brot und Frieden darum
geht es um diesen Winter danke schön
Kassen Leihe hat noch mal darauf
hingewiesen dass auf der Angebotsseite
Energie dringend etwas passieren muss
denn in der Tat besteht ja die Gefahr
wie auch immer finanziert das ist zu
wenig Energie in Deutschland geben kann
tillmannsmann jetzt für die FDP
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
seit Monaten verfolgen wir tagtäglich
wieder russische Angriffskrieg in der
Ukraine zu unendlich viel Leid bei den
Betroffenen vor Ort führt jeden Tag
sterben hunderte von Menschen Familien
werden getrennt das Resultat von Leben
harter Arbeit wird zerstört das alles im
Zuge eines sinnlosen Krieges für den
hauptsächlich einen einziger Mann die
Verantwortung trägt wenn derartiges
Unrecht stattfindet dürfen wir das nicht
einfach hinnehmen für uns Freie
Demokraten war deshalb von Anfang an
klar dass die Ukraine den Krieg gewinnen
muss und Finanzminister Christian
lindert auch gerade klargemacht dass das
im Kern von dem steht was wir heute ja
auch wirtschaftlich machen wollen wir
lassen nicht zu dass unser Land durch
hoher Energiepreise gespalten wird
die Energiepreisentwicklung der
vergangenen Monate führt uns deutlich
vor Augen in was für eine unsägliche
Abhängigkeit die verfehlte
Energiepolitik der vergangenen Jahre uns
geführt hat und lieber Kollege
Mittelberg davon haben sie leider nichts
gesagt wer dafür verantwortlich ist
nun benutzt Russland Energie als Waffe
gegen uns mit weiteren Gaslieferungen
aus Russland ist endgültig nicht mehr zu
rechnen die Situation spielt sich
deshalb täglich weiter zu und der
gestern von Bundeskanzler Scholz im
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Habeck und
Bundesfinanzminister Lindner
angekündigte wirtschaftliche
abwehrschirmen gegen die Folgen des
russischen Angriffskrieg nimmt eine
zentrale Rolle bei der Bewältigung
dieses enorm dieser enorme
Herausforderungen an die Ampelkoalition
beweist damit ein weiteres Mal
Handlungsfähigkeit in einer schweren
Krise
der vorliegende Gesetzesentwurf der
Senkung der Umsatzsteuer auf
Gaslieferung und Fernwärme ist ein
wichtiger Teil eben dieses
angesprochenen abwehrschirms die
derzeitigen Kosten beim Gas belasten
eben nicht nur den Staat und die
Betriebe sondern auch die vielen
privaten Haushalte in unserem Land immer
mehr Menschen erreichen in diesen Tagen
Briefe mit unerfreundlichen Nachrichten
übersteigende Abschlagszahlungen viele
fragen sich wie das noch bezahlbar sein
soll wenn sich die Preise innerhalb
weniger Monate so stark erhöhen um es
deutlich zu sagen wir müssen jetzt
handeln damit die Bürger unseres Landes
gut durch den Winter kommen
mit dem vorliegenden Gesetzesentwurf
entlasten wir Millionen Menschen um über
13 Milliarden Euro 13 Milliarden Euro
mehr in den Taschen der Steuerzahler wo
sie mit Blick auf die kommenden Monate
auch am besten aufgehoben sind deshalb
appelliere ich sie an dieser Stelle
liebe Kollegen dem vorliegenden
Gesetzesentwurf zuzustimmen sodass wir
die Entlastung der Bürger schnell auf
den Weg bringen können vielen Dank
[Applaus]
nächster Redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
Alois Rainer
Alois Rainer von der CSU ist der
Vorsitzende des Finanzausschusses
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir haben diese
Woche sehr ausführlich lange im
Ausschuss über die Mehrwertsteuersenkung
auf Gas diskutiert dann kam nach
Beschlussfassung die Bitte um eine
Sondersitzung weil wir auch die
Mehrwertsteuersenkung auf Fernwärme noch
beschließen sollten und haben wir auch
dementsprechend gemacht lieber Kollege
des parlamentarische Verfahren wurde
somit auch eingehalten aber ob die
parlamentarische Diskussion möglich war
im Vorfeld das steht wieder auf einem
ganz anderen Papier aber
aber nichtsdestotrotz einer
Mehrwertsteuersenkung auf Gas und
Fernwärme können wir als Union guten
Gewissens zustimmen obwohl sie unseren
Antrag zur Senkung der Mehrwertsteuer
auf Gasstrom und man hörte Fernwärme im
Februar noch abgelehnt haben freut es
mich umso mehr dass sie nun zur Einsicht
gekommen sind und
unsere Lösungen akzeptieren und somit
auch bis heute abschließend beschlossen
werden schaue eigentlich
dass so viel Zeit verloren gegangen ist
es geht nicht um die Zeit die wir im
Plenum verloren haben sondern es geht um
das Geld der Menschen in unserem Land
das in dieser Zeit verplempert worden
ist
etwas weniger Zeit haben sie gebraucht
um einzusehen dass zumindest zwei
Atomkraftwerke jetzt auch zumindest im
streckbetrieb was meines auch nicht
reichen wird weiter betrieben werden
weil folgelösungen für Gas und Öl noch
nicht vorliegen sinnvoll und notwendig
bei dem derzeit wachsenden Strombedarf
wäre es auch das dritte dafür in Frage
kommende Atomkraftwerk in Niedersachsen
ebenfalls weiterlaufen zu lassen aber
wer weiß was wer weiß was dann nach der
Wahl in Niedersachsen alles noch kommt
aber dafür
aber dafür kommt ja jetzt
zumindest der strompreisdeckel oder
zumindest neben den strompreisdeckel
auch der gaspreisdeckel was den
strompreisdeckel und des abschöpfen der
zufallsgewinne in Anführungszeichen
anbelangt da bin ich am Ende der Tage
mal gespannt wie das funktioniert und
wie auch die Verteilung funktionieren
soll welcher doppelwumms oder Triple
Wums ist am Ende der Tage werden wird
wissen wir noch nicht ich würde eher
dafür plädieren dass wir auf den
schnellsten Weg in der Europäischen
Union ein darauf einwirken dass wir die
strommarktdesign ändert nämlich dies
mehr it
order-system ändert weil dann können wir
das Problem was den zumindest den Strom
anbelangt an der Wurzel packen und das
Konzept für die gaspreisbremse soll
vielleicht wenn man glück kommt erst
Mitte Oktober vorlegen dabei liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen gibt es doch
schon brauchbare Modelle auch bei den
Nachbarländern die sie oft auch zitieren
kommen wir aber zum weiteren Punkt der
noch angehängt worden ist an diesen
Tages Zeitpunkt auch im Ausschuss und
auch jetzt die Steuerbefreiung der
Inflationsausgleich Sonderzahlungen der
Arbeitgeber in Höhe von 3.000 Euro ich
habe in einer meiner letzten Rede gesagt
sie schmücken sich mit fremden Federn
und auch diesmal passiert es wieder so
dass man sich mit fremden Federn
schmückt die Arbeitgeber und Arbeitgeber
werden wieder zur Kasse gebeten uns sie
werden unter Druck gesetzt natürlich ist
es etwas Gutes für alle
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer wenn
Sie einen Bonus von 3.000 Euro erhalten
aber man darf zurzeit auf keinen Fall
vergessen welche Belastungen die
Betriebe in unserem Land sowieso schon
haben neben der Erhöhung des
Mindestlohnes der sich nicht nur auf die
unteren lohnschichten auswirkt sondern
eine Wirkung auch für die oberen
lohnschichten haben haben sie zu kämpfen
auch mit der Inflation haben sie zu
kämpfen mit gestörten Lieferketten haben
sie zu kämpfen mit Personalmangel aber
vor allem haben sie zu kämpfen mit
erhöhten Energiekosten und
Energiepreisen und dann das auch so noch
dazu es ist schön wie gesagt wenn man so
ein Geschenk verteilen kann aber ich
möchte jetzt meine abschließende
Redezeit dazu noch nutzen dass ich den
Betrieben in unserem Land mit ihren
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern einmal
ein ganz großes Dankeschön aussprechen
denn sie sind es die dieses Chaos des
sie verursachen nämlich meistern müssen
sie sind es die wettbewerbsfähig bleiben
wollen und nicht in den Winterschlaf
gehen wollen die nicht einfach aufhören
wollen zu produzieren die sich für ihre
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter
einsetzen und Lösungen überlegen damit
diese bei auch teils eingeschränkter
Produktion weiterbeschäftigt werden
können Sie
die Betriebe die Betriebe in unserem
Land mit ihren Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeitern stemmen momentan einen
Großteil unserer Wertschöpfung in
unseren Land sie schauen das weiterhin
Dienstleistungen angeboten werden können
und versuchen die mühsam gewonnenen
Fachkräfte auch zu halten und sie halten
dahingehend auch unser Land zusammen und
Liebe Bundesregierung ich appelliere an
Sie geben Sie der Wirtschaft und den
Menschen in unserem Land eine klare
Linie nicht nur kurzfristige Änderungen
ja ich stehe aber noch nicht genau drin
was es am Ende der Tage bedeuten soll
also wir haben überhand den 200
Milliarden 2.5-seitiges Papier erhalten
aber wie sie es am Ende der Tage
Umsetzen des wissen wir jetzt noch nicht
die Menschen haben es satt in unserem
Landes sage ich Ihnen dass Sie die
Probleme immer erst in allerletzter
Sekunde angehen vielleicht auch ein
Stück weit lösen Planungssicherheit
Planungssicherheit liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
Kollegen ist das was unsere Wirtschaft
und die Gesellschaft brauchen sorgen sie
für Energiesicherheit in unserem Land
sorgen sie für den Erhalt der
Arbeitsplätze in dem genug Energie
vorhanden ist um alle produktionsstränge
aufrecht zu erhalten zu können und damit
einen Anstieg der Arbeitslosigkeit zu
verhindern und den Wohlstand in unserem
Land beizubehalten dankeschön
Alois seiner hat es angesprochen neben
der umsatzsteuersenkung auf Gas und
Fernwärme übrigens auch 14 Prozent der
Haushalte in Deutschland werden mit
Fernwärme Betrieben beheizbaron ist es
so dass in diesem Gesetz hier heute auch
der Posten verabschiedet wird das
Arbeitgeber ein Bonus 3000 Euro
steuerfrei auszahlen können
Carlos Casper für die SPD in ihrer Rede
gesagt wir machen die Politik wegen
unseres Chaos dass wir verursacht haben
ich möchte an dieser Stelle nochmal
erinnern dass es ihr
Fraktionsvorsitzender war der im März
nordsteam 1 schließen wollte mit allen
Konsequenzen mit leeren gasspeichern vor
diesen Winter mit horrenden Gaspreisen
und sie haben keine Lösung für diese
Probleme das hat man an ihren
Redebeiträgen gerade gemerkt
aber warum machen wir heute diese
Politik um was geht es denn bei dieser
Politik es geht um die Bäcker die
Existenznöte haben bei ihre Gasrechnung
zu hoch sind es geht um die Bäcker die
Angst haben weil sie keinen Brot mehr
backen können und wenn dann nur noch zu
solchen Preisen dieses niemand mehr
leisten kann es geht um die Unternehmen
es geht beispielsweise um Unternehmen
der Chemieindustrie die in meinen
Wahlkreis Vorprodukte führt
Desinfektionsmittel herstellen es geht
um den schulcaterer der Angst hat vor
der Insolvenz und wird dieser Insolvenz
einhergehen würde das Kinder kein warmes
Mittagessen mehr hätten es geht um die
Familie die einfach Angst hat dass Sie
Ihre Heizkosten nicht zahlen kann und
genau für diese Menschen da draußen für
die Leute im Land machen wir heute diese
Politik
deswegen führen wir die Gas und
Strompreise Bremse ein wir greifen ein
in den Markt und stoppen die
exportierenden Energiekosten belegen 200
Milliarden Euro auf den Tisch damit die
gaspreisbremse endlich kommt und mit ihr
die Existenznöte gehen
mit dem Abwehrschirm setzen wir den
steigenden Energiekosten etwas entgegen
und Federn die schwersten Folgen für
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher sowie
für Unternehmen ab niemand muss Angst
haben in diesem Winter zu frieren
niemand muss Angst haben seinen
Arbeitsplatz zu verlieren niemand muss
Angst haben dass unsere Wirtschaft diese
Krise nicht übersteht es gilt was der
Kanzler gesagt hat you will never walk
alone
und auch dieses Gesetz dass wir heute in
zweiter dritte Lesung beschließen ist
ein weiterer Beweis dass wir den
Menschen gezielt unter die Arme greifen
mit weiteren 13 Milliarden Euro
bekämpfen wir die exorbitanten
Energiepreise und senken die
Mehrwertsteuer auf
gas-angst hat haben muss vor einer
kalten Wohnung und deswegen ist dieses
Gesetz zur Mehrwertsteuersenkung so
wichtig denn es betrifft eben nicht nur
Menschen mit kleinerem Einkommen die
Energiekrise betrifft auch den
Mittelstand das Handwerk und Unternehmen
generell dieses Gesetz ist eine ganz
direkte Antwort darauf dass viele
Anbieter von ihren Kundinnen und Kunden
bereits Wochenende Abschlagszahlungen
gefordert haben diese sind hinfällig und
müssen zurückgenommen werden
und ganz besonders möchte ich
hervorheben dass wir auch die
Mehrwertsteuer auf Fernwärme senken das
ist insbesondere für die Menschen im
Osten wichtig denn dort gibt es ein gut
ausgebautes Fernwärmenetz durch das
viele Wohnungen in Ostdeutschland
beliefert werden in Dresden sind es 40
Prozent in Zwickau sind es sogar fast 50
Prozent die Ihre Heizung mit Fernwärme
betreiben so schaffen wir eine gerechte
Entlastung für ein Großteil der
Bevölkerung und auch das sollte nicht
unerwähnt bleiben es war die
SPD-Fraktion die sich am Anfang des
Monats bei ihrer Klausuren Dresden
festgelegt hat dass wir in den
markteingreifen müssen um diese enorm
Energiepreise zu deckeln es war die
SPD-Fraktion die unverschämte Gewinne
abschöpfen will und es ist die
SPD-Fraktion die nicht nur Papiere
schreibt sondern diese Politik in
Gesetzesform gießt
das Land ist im krisenmodus Krise heißt
für die Politik handeln Dinge abwägen
und Entscheidungen treffen das tun wir
als andere Regierung mit vielen Gesetzen
wir beschließen heute dass wir den
Arbeitgebern in diesem Land ermöglichen
an ihren Beschäftigten 3000 Euro Steuer
und sozialabgabenfrei zu zahlen dieses
Geld kann gestaffelt bis 2024 ausgezahlt
werden und hilft gezielt der arbeitenden
Mitte der Gesellschaft aber auch mit der
energiepreispauschale die jetzt mit dem
September Lohn ausgezahlt wird helfen
wir den Beschäftigten in diesem Land und
auch die Rentner und Rentner sowie die
Studierenden profitieren von unserer
Politik außerdem helfen wir das Wohngeld
und spannen mit dem neuen Bürgergeld ein
starkes soziales Netz auch
und wisst ihr was heute ist heute ist
der 30.09 heute ist der letzte Tag an
dem unverschämte Löhne gezahlt werden ab
morgen bekommen in meinem Wahlkreis
allein 50.000 Menschen mehr lohnen ab
morgen geht der Mindestlohn von 12 Euro
nächster Redner für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen dr Sebastian Schäfer
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen mit 200
Milliarden Euro als Abwehrschirm gegen
die Energiekrise handeln wir
entschlossen wir halten unser Land in
dieser schwierigen Zeit zusammen wir
ergeben unseren Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
Sicherheit indem wir jetzt den Anstieg
der Energiepreise für Strom und Wärme so
deutlich begrenzen und wir geben damit
unseren Unternehmen unserer
mittelständischen Industrie unserem
Handwerk ein klares Signal den Kern
unserer Volkswirtschaft den Kern unseres
Wohlstands lassen wir von einem
russischen Diktator nicht zerstören
wir lassen uns
nicht erschüttern nicht einschüchtern
als DemokratInnen und Demokraten in
diesem Land
200 Milliarden
sind dann mächtiger Schutzschirm mit dem
wir dafür sorgen dass die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger der Mittelstand das Handwerk
aber auch soziale Einrichtungen
Kindergärten Pflegeheime sicher durch
den Winter kommen
zusätzlich entlasten wir die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger durch die Senkung der
Umsatzsteuer für Gas und Fernwärme um
einen zweistelligen Milliardenbetrag das
ist erheblich und das hilft sehr direkt
als
Finanz- und Haushaltspolitiker Schmerzen
mich 200 Milliarden Euro neue Schulden
sehr ganz besonders wenn das Geld im
Wesentlichen für fossile Energie
ausgegeben wird
wir begleichen damit einen Teil der
Rechnung die wir für unsere Abhängigkeit
von Putins Gas bezahlen müssen
das sind ihre Schulden sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
das sind die Konsequenzen ihrer
Zechprellerei die wir jetzt übernehmen
müssen
wir werden die gaspreisbremse so
konstruieren dass der Anreiz zum
Energiesparen erhalten bleibt das hat
Veronika Grimm die der Kommission zur
gaspreisbremse vorsitzt heute in der FAZ
sehr deutlich unterstrichen
umso wichtiger ist es dass wir jetzt
auch zusätzliche Energieeffizienz und
erneuerbare Energien investieren denn
ein zurück zu billigen fossilen Energien
die nie billig waren wird es nicht geben
unsere Wirtschaft hat bei der Effizienz
schon große Fortschritte gemacht und
nutzt Effizienzverbesserungen wo sie
kann auch viele Bürgerinnen und Bürger
sind solidarisch und tun was sie können
um jetzt Energie zu sparen
mit der aktuellen Überarbeitung des
energiesicherungsgesetzes legen wir
erneut etwas vor wir werden es später in
der Debatte hören das sind Ausbau und
die Nutzung der erneuerbaren Energien
noch einmal erheblich steigern wird der
biogasdeckel wird wegfallen und es wird
noch bessere Möglichkeiten für Solar und
PV-Anlagen geben auch steuerlich setzen
wir da neue Anreize und lösen endlich
bürokratische fesseln
erneuerbare Energien sind der beste Weg
um unsere Energieversorgung in
Deutschland abzusichern so machen wir
uns in und nach dieser Krise
unabhängiger von teuren Importen von Gas
Öl oder Kohle und schützen obendrein das
Klima
denn wir
wollen keine Zechprellerei auf Kosten
künftiger Generationen betreiben deshalb
machen wir in dieser
fortschrittskoalition unser Land auch in
schwierigen Zeiten zukunftsfest
herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
nächster Redner für die SPD-Fraktion
parsa Mavi
ist Mitglied im Finanzausschuss für die
SPD sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen in den
vergangenen Wochen erleben wir alle die
in den Wahlkreisen unterwegs sind bei
den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern bei den
Betrieben bei den Sportvereinen bei den
sozialen Einrichtungen eine Menge für
unsicherung angesichts bereits
eingegangener Energie
abschlagsforderungen die zum Teil
mehrere hundert Prozent über den
bisherigen Niveau liegen oder erwarteter
signifikante teurerung gleichzeitig
erleben wir eine Abkühlung
wirtschaftliche Indikatoren die auf eine
schwierige die auf schwierige kommende
Monate hindeuten das ist eine kritische
Situation die einer nationalen
gemeinsamen nationalen
Kraftanstrengungen Bedarf zu der wir ja
heute schon einiges von der Opposition
gehört haben und die eine entschlossenen
und konsequenten Antwort durch die
Politik Bedarf die diese Bundesregierung
gestern erneut eindrucksvoll geliefert
hat mit einer großen Geschlossenheit
zwischen Olaf Scholz Christian lindern
Robert Habeck zwischen den ampelpartnern
das war gestern ein whatever it
takesmoment ein ganz wichtiges Signal in
das Land hinein liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
diese Bundesregierung die Ampelkoalition
befindet sich seit ihrem Amtsantritt und
insbesondere seit der Zeitenwende vom 24
februar in permanenten krisenmodus wir
wissen dass es Angesicht sich ständig
verändernder lagen auf die wir stetig
und angemessen reagieren müssen neben
einer strategischen Orientierung eine
ordentlichen Portion pragmatismusbedarf
um dieser Krise entgegen zu wirken
Eigenschaften auf die die Union
eigentlich über viele Jahre bei ihrer
krisenkanzlerin Angela Merkel stolz war
aber diese 16 Jahre scheinen ja schon
lange her zu sein liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
seit Monaten seit Monaten steht diese
Ampelkoalition voll auf dem Platz mit
einfach doppelwurms und wenn es sein
muss auch dreifachwumms wir liefern und
bringen Monat für Monat Plenarwoche für
Plenarwoche Gesetze durch das Parlament
und wir haben eine vollhandlungsfähige
Bundesregierung was
was ist in diesem turbulenten ja nicht
schon alles geschehen oder auf dem Weg
meine Kollegen haben es vorhin
angedeutet die staatliche Rettung von
Juniper das erste Entlastungspaket im
ersten Halbjahr mit über 30 Milliarden
Euro die Einigung im Koalitionsausschuss
Anfang September mit Entlassung über 65
Milliarden Euro Direktzahlungen die
Eindämmung der kalten Progression die
große wohngeldreform die Anhebung des
Grundfreibetrags und vieles mehr und
jetzt in dieser Woche die entscheidend
meine Damen und Herren Sie sehen es in
dem kleinen Fenster
Karl Lauterbach und Lothar Wieler der
RKI-Präsident und der Bundesminister
haben hier Platz genommen in der
Bundespressekonferenz Corona ist ein
bisschen in Vergessenheit geraten wenn
ich das richtig gelesen habe haben wir
mittlerweile mehr Tote in diesem Herbst
als vor einem Jahr also nicht zu
unterschätzen und deswegen wollen wir
Ihnen diese Pressekonferenz hier heute
morgen übertragen wir kommen dann
nachher wieder hierhin zurück in den
Deutschen Bundestag
diesen Freitag morgen so
Berichterstattung über die aktuelle
corona-lage begrüße ich den
Bundesminister für Gesundheit Karl
Lauterbach und ich begrüße den
Präsidenten des Robert-Koch-Institutes
Notar wieder sein sonst herzlich
willkommen NW wertermann hier beginnen
sie Minister bitteschön lieber Väter ich
darf mich zunächst einmal erneut ganz
herzlich für die Möglichkeit hier zu
berichten bedanken meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren
wie sie alle wissen trifft morgen das
neue Infektionsschutzgesetz in Kraft das
ist ein guter Zeitpunkt noch einmal auf
infektionslage hinzuweisen und über ein
paar Dinge zu berichten
es Ihnen ermöglichen sich an Bild
darüber zu machen was da in den nächsten
Wochen kommen wird und ob wir also gut
vorbereitet sind
ich danke auch Herrn Wieler dass er
heute mit von der Partie ist und seine
Bereitschaft erklärt hat ebenfalls und
Auskunft zu erteilen Cola steht im
Moment nicht so stark im Vordergrund
nicht so stark im Licht der
Öffentlichkeit
andere Krisen sind wichtiger und ich
glaube das ist an uns ist auch dafür zu
sorgen dass das so bleibt das Corona
sich nicht stärker in den Vordergrund
schieben wird und das haben wir aus
meiner Sicht in der Hand aber es wird
nicht von alleine kommen wir werden also
viel zu tun haben eine zusätzliche
Stresssituation in diesem Herbst und in
diesem Winter zu vermeiden und es ist
also für uns sehr wichtig dass also die
Folgen des ukrainerkriegs die hart genug
sind nicht auch noch durch also
corona-fälle und durch eine Überlastung
der kritischen Infrastruktur und sehr
viele Krankheitsfälle erschwert oder
überlagert werden wir befinden uns ganz
klar am Beginn einer herbst- und
winterwelle
das ist nicht nur eine deutsche Daten zu
sehen sondern auch international die
Fallzahlen steigen an in den
Niederlanden in Belgien in Frankreich in
England in Dänemark und nur ein paar
Länder zu nennen fast überall ist es die
ba5 Variante die Probleme hier also
bereitet und wir müssen uns daher darauf
einstellen dass diese Welle bekämpft
werden muss die wird nicht so schnell
zumindest von alleine enden und der
R-Wert ist mittlerweile schon bei
ungefähr 1,4 das ist ein sehr hoher
erwert auch im Vergleich zu dem was wir
vorher gesehen haben und wir müssen
daher damit rechnen dass Fahrt sein auch
wieder vierstellig sein Können in nicht
allzu ferner Zukunft und das wird noch
erschwert weil wir auch mit mehrere
Zunahme der Fallzahlen für
Grippeerkrankungen und andere
Erkältungserkrankungen zum Beispiel
andere corona-erkrankungen oc43 oder
renoviren zu rechnen haben aber auch R
Power bei Kindern somit sind wir am
Beginn einer wichtigen schwierigen Welle
wir werden der Wähler begegnen durch
vier Blöcke wenn man so will zum einen
werden eine Impfkampagne machen die
Impfstoffe sind da angepasst Impfstoffe
ba1 angepasst ba5 angepasst wir haben
deutlich mehr Impfstoff aus derzeit
verimpft wird es werden derzeit also pro
Tag etwa 60.000 Menschen geimpft das ist
weit weniger als wir benötigen wir haben
große ebenpflücken bei den über
60-Jährigen zum Beispiel fehlt bei 75%
der also über 60-Jährigen bis zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt die vierte Impfung
aber die gute Nachricht ist wir haben
die guten Impfstoffe die angepassten
Impfstoffe und wir können Sie jetzt zur
Verfügung stellen wir werden dort keine
Engpässe erleben wir haben auch eine
klare stikoempfehlung für die über
60-Jährigen und die Risikofaktoren und
wir werden an der Kampagne beginnen die
wird spätestens in zwei Wochen wird die
über viele Kanäle also wird die
stattfinden über also Printmedien über
soziale Medien bis in die Fernsehmedien
Radio mitten hinein wir haben uns dort
auch bemüht eine innovative Kampagne auf
den Weg zu bringen da werden wir die
Impfkampagne noch einmal deutlich
beschleunigen das ist sozusagen der
erste Punkt über dem Ganzen begegnen zum
zweiten wir haben uns ja dafür
eingesetzt schon seit Wochen dass die
Patienten die davon besser profitieren
wenn sie medikamentös behandelt werden
auch medikamentös behandelt werden
gespielt insbesondere das Medikament
paxovit eine Rolle packstovit senkt die
Wahrscheinlichkeit eines
Krankenhausaufenthaltes bei den älteren
Menschen um 75 Prozent wenn es
rechtzeitig genommen wird das wissen wir
aus israelischen Daten auch die
Sterblichkeit wird abgesenkt wir haben
dort in den letzten Wochen eine
Verdreifachung der paxlovitgabe gesehen
dass eine sehr gute Nachricht und wir
werden aber weiter daran arbeiten Ärzte
können das Medikament selbst
distanzieren es wird gelagert in
Pflegeeinrichtungen somit eine deutliche
Verbesserung der medikamentösen ther sie
nicht nur mit Wachstum wird aber vor
allem mit Park so getan werden wir
weiter arbeiten und wie Sie wissen hat
sich auch der Bundeskanzler ja dazu
entschieden dieses Medikament
einzunehmen um einen schweren Verlauf zu
vermeiden der dritte also Punkte hier
beachtet werden muss wir haben bessere
Daten der pandemierader kommt jetzt
sukzessive ans Netz eine erste Version
ist vor 15 Minuten
auf der Homepage des RKI Seins Netz
gestellt worden und wer ist noch nicht
komplett aber das ist schon ein ganz
wichtiger Schritt nach vorne die
krankenhausbelegung da werden wir
demnächst die also belegten und die
belegbaren Betten haben also nicht die
aufgestellten sondern die belegbaren
Betten von den 1600 Krankenhäusern die
hier berichten müssen sind schon 1300
Krankenhäuser mittlerweile angeschlossen
ja sind eine repräsentative Zahl von
Krankenhäusern die angeschlossen sind
noch nicht alle melden daran wird aber
sehr intensiv gearbeitet
wir haben also dann eine gute Übersicht
über die Praxen die also hier sogenannte
sentinelparks sind wo man schaut wie
also welche Atemwegserkrankungen tauchen
in den Praxen auf ich schwer verlaufen
die das ist angeschlossen da hat sich ja
wieder in der Vergangenheit auch immer
wieder zugeordnet und verdient gemacht
er wird sicherlich gleich ausführen und
wir haben das Wasser abwassermonitor in
den Vorbereitungen das ist heute noch
nicht auf der Seite zu sehen da
schließen wir aber die
schließen wir die abwassermessstellen
sukzessive an und bereinigen das
Auswerteverfahren ich gehe davon aus
dass wir in zwei Wochen da schon
wesentlich bessere Daten zur Verfügung
haben der Herbst wird nicht leicht
werden damit bin ich auch schon der bei
der vierten also Maßnahme die wir haben
das eben erst das Infektionsschutzgesetz
und die Länder müssen halt bei der
Entwicklung der Fassaden darauf achten
dass Sie den richtigen Zeitpunkt
erwischen wo sie Maßnahmen die das
infektions dieses Gesetz ermöglicht auch
ergreifen das muss von den Ländern jetzt
ganz genau beobachtet werden wie gesagt
der pandemierer da steht zur Verfügung
die internationalen Daten sind klar die
also neue Welle kommt das wird Herr
Wille auch gleich ausführen somit ist
jetzt nur die Frage wann steigen die
Länder mit den Maßnahmen ein und
versuchen die Welle abzubremsen
abzuflachen mit welchen Maßnahmen wir
haben ja umfängliche Maßnahmen wie Sie
wissen ist unser Infektionsschutzgesetz
konservativer und erlaubt mehr als die
meisten Schutzgesetze in anderen
europäischen Ländern da bin dafür sind
wir als
Bundesgesundheitsministerium nicht nur
gelobt worden es gab auch kritische
Stimmen aber ich bin sicher dass das
richtig ist denn die Welle die wir jetzt
bekommen die wir zeigen dass wir diese
Maßnahmen auch benötigen und ich
appelliere an die Länder jetzt genau im
Auge zu warten genau den Zeitpunkt zu
erwischen wo man jetzt gut einsteigt um
sich zum Beispiel zu überlegen wann soll
denn in den Innenräumen wieder
eingetragen werden und also was passiert
in den Schulen denn diese Welle wird
sich so schnell nicht von alleine
begrenzen weshalb ist das alles wichtig
naja wenn wir die Welle nicht begrenzen
dann kann es sein dass wir in ein paar
Wochen Probleme haben bei der kritischen
Infrastruktur Pflegepersonal
beispielsweise ärztliches Personal
Polizisten kritische Infrastruktur jeder
Art kann also angesprochen sein wir
könnten auch sehr schnell in eine
Situation kommen wo wir nicht genug
belegbare Betten haben weil die Kerze
brennt dann ja von beiden Enden ich habe
dann weniger Personal was diese Betten
belegbar macht das werden wir dann im
Pandemie Monitor ja sehen dass die Zahl
der belegbaren Betten auch abnimmt weil
weniger Personal noch gesund ist und
gleichzeitig kommen mehr Leute in diese
Betten rein und von daher also wird dann
sehr schnell eine Situation auch zu
diskutieren sein wie viele belegbare
Betten haben wir noch und wie viel
Vorlauf brauchen wir um die Welle
abzuwehren und da wird pandemiera da
eben sehr wichtig sein da werden wir zum
Beispiel sehen an den abwasserdaten ob
die Lage sich entspannt oder ob sie es
nicht tut eine gute Nachricht ist dass
wir also bisher keine varianten sehen
also beispielsweise in UK aber auch
nicht in anderen Ländern die also die
Sterblichkeit oder die schweren Verläufe
der data Variante kombinieren würde mit
der immunflucht der also
Omegon ba5 Variante oder ähnlichen
Varianten das ist die gute Nachricht die
nicht ganz so gute Nachricht ist dass
wir einige Varianten wir sehen wie zum
Beispiel
bq1.1 aber auch andere die eine sehr
vollständige immunflucht haben das
bedeutet dass wir dort mit Impfungen
möglicherweise nicht so viel erreichen
können wie jetzt bei ba5 und das müssen
wir auch im Auge behalten also darauf
müssen wir vorbereitet sein da bin ich
allerdings auch schon im Gespräch mit
den also Unternehmungen die also
Impfstoffe produzieren also wir haben es
auch im Auge und es könnte sein
verbessern die Impfstoffe wieder
angepasst werden also auch dann wären
wir nicht hilflos auch darauf sind wir
vorbereitet und werden das also den in
den Griff bekommen zum Schluss wie
gesagt auf der ikrki.de Seite pandemera
da abrufen dann können Sie sehen wie das
in Zukunft aussehen wird 60.000 Menschen
werden derzeit geimpft die Impfkampagne
ist in der Vorbereitung ich will noch
einmal abschließend auf den Wert der
vierten Impfung Hinweis weil das wird
immer wieder unterschätzt das sind ja
nur wie gesagt 25 Prozent bei den über
60-Jährigen die die vierte Impfung haben
die vierte Impfung reduziert bei
denjenigen die schon dreimal geimpft
sind die also Sterblichkeit zum Beispiel
auf der Grundlage von gestern gezeigten
CDC da hatten aus den Vereinigten
Staaten noch einmal um 90 Prozent das
heißt es macht für ältere Menschen einen
riesen Unterschied ob man dreimal
geimpft ist oder ob man Firma geben das
macht einfach einen riesigen Unterschied
und das wird aus meiner Sicht zu wenig
komm passiert wenn ich durch eine
zusätzliche booster-impfung das Risiko
zu versterben um 90% senken kann und
diese Möglichkeit wird bei den über
60-Jährigen nur zu 25% genutzt haben wir
hier eine impflücke die nicht wirklich
akzeptabel ist diese impflücke werden
wir ganz gezielt ansprechend auch mit
unserer Impfkampagne wir sind somit am
Beginn einer neuen Welle die sind aber
gut vorbereitet und ich bin
zuversichtlich wir werden das im Griff
haben und wir werden es erreichen dass
Corona auch ein Thema für diesen Herbst
ist aber nicht das dominierende Thema
ist und die Probleme die wir in anderen
Bereichen haben nicht noch schwerer
macht
vielen Dank Herr Minister ja ich möchte
zunächst einen Überblick geben über die
Atemwegsinfektionen allgemein die wir in
Deutschland zählen im nicht nur zu Kurve
19 der Herbst hat begonnen und dann
nimmt die Zahl der Atemwegserkrankungen
zu das ist auch gar nicht ungewöhnlich
das sehen wir praktisch in jedem Jahr
und zwar immer zum Herbst beginnen in
diesem Jahr allerdings ist der Anstieg
besonders stark um in ein paar Zahlen
aus unseren zweien Systemen zu nennen
die wir ja schon seit einigen Jahren
betreiben letzte Woche sind hierzulande
rund 7,7 Millionen Menschen neu einander
akuten Atemwegsinfektion erkrankt das
ist fast jeder zehnte in der Bevölkerung
Kinder und junge Erwachsene sind davon
momentan besonders betroffen
und 1,2 Millionen Menschen haben wegen
einer akuten Atemwegserkrankung eine
Arztpraxis aufgesucht all diese Zahlen
liegen deutlich höher als in den
Vorjahren und auch deutlich höher als in
den vor pandemischen Jahren die meisten
Erkrankungen werden im Moment übrigens
nicht durch Corona hervorgerufen sondern
durch renovieren das ist ein klassischer
gutbekannter Erreger von
schnupfenerkrankungen dann kommt saskow
2 an der zweiten Stelle außerdem werden
noch verschiedene andere Regeln
nachgewiesen zum Beispiel dass rsv-virus
oder auch influenza
was bedeutet das aber nun im Hinblick
auf covid 19 für die kommenden Monate
vorab
die Pandemie ist noch nicht vorbei auch
wenn wir uns in einer relativ günstigen
und stabilen Situation befinden und Herr
Minister Lauterbach hatte ihn eben
genannt was für alles tun damit das auch
so bleibt wir haben mit einer moderaten
virusvariante zu tun
wir haben Zugang zu Impfstoffen und
Therapeutika und ein Großteil der
Bevölkerung hat bereits eine covid 19
Infektion durchlebt
aber im Moment können sich viele
verschiedene atemwegserreger ziemlich
ungebremst in der Bevölkerung ausbreiten
es finden viel übertragen statt der
Infektionsdruck ist also hoch
da sehen wir auch aktuell bei den Coven
19 Daten die Inzidenzen sind wieder
gestiegen die sieben Tage Inzidenz liegt
jetzt auch schon wieder bundesweit bei
über 400 von Kurve 19 sind im Moment vor
allen Dingen die mittleren Altersgruppen
betroffen nicht so sehr die Jüngeren
wird bei anderen
Atemwegsinfektionen die gute Nachricht
ist
dass wir noch keinen massiven Anstieg
bei den Krankenhauseinweisungen sehen
auch nicht bei den Todesfällen hier
müssen wir die Situation aber natürlich
weiter beobachten und dafür haben wir ja
die Werkzeuge die gerade erläutert
wurden denn schwere Verläufe die nehmen
ja auch erst mit etwas Zeitverzug ab das
haben wir in den letzten Jahren ja alle
gelernt
wir müssen also covid 19 weiter ernst
nehmen sarskow 2 ist immer noch ein
vergleichsweise neues Virus über das wir
immer noch nicht alles wissen
kovid 19 kann schwer verlaufen auch sehr
schwer verlaufen es kann zu schweren
Langzeitfolgen führen und wir können
eben nicht vorhersehen wie sich das
Virus weiterentwickeln wird
unser Ziel für diesen Herbst ist
weiterhin die Anzahl von covid 19 Fällen
und anderen akuten atemwegserkranken
nicht Überschießen zu lassen damit
schwere Krankheitsverläufe wirklich
bestmöglich verhindert werden die
meisten dieser Infektionen verlaufen
zwar mild
aber sarskopf 2 und Grippeviren können
bei Menschen aus Risikogruppen eben auch
zu sehr schweren Verläufen führen und
auch zu Todesfällen und auch bei
mildenverläufen liegen ja viele
Betroffene krank im Bett und können dann
nicht arbeiten gehen
das wiederum wird in vielen Bereichen zu
personalentpässen führen ein milder
Verlauf bedeutet eigentlich nur dass
jemand eben nicht ins Krankenhaus muss
wir fällen meine Damen und Herren jeder
von uns fällt jeden Tag Entscheidungen
auch in der jetzigen Situation sollten
wir uns bewusst sein welches Risiko wir
eingehen wollen
und welches wir vermeiden können was
also kann jeder und jeder Einzelne tun
um Atemwegsinfekte zu reduzieren die
meisten Tipps sind ihnen bekannt aus der
Kurve 19 Pandemie sie wirken aber
genauso gut bei allen anderen
atemwegserregern vor allem auch gegen
Grippe und das haben wir in den letzten
Jahren sehr klar gesehen und belegt
erstens und dieser Punkt ist im Hinblick
auf die Energiekrise auch besonders
wichtig Innenräume sollten bitte
trotzdem regelmäßig gelüftet werden je
mehr Menschen sich in einem Raum
befinden desto häufiger wichtig ist dass
die Luft ausgetauscht wird also mit
Stoßlüften dabei geht viel weniger Wärme
verloren als zum Beispiel dauerhaft
gekipptem Fenster aber bitte verzichten
Sie nicht auf das Lüften zweitens wenn
sie Erkältungssymptome haben bitte
bleiben Sie drei bis fünf Tage zu Hause
bis sich die Symptome gebessert haben zu
verhindern sie einfach weitere
Übertragungen in ihrem Umfeld sei es am
Arbeitsplatz in der Schule oder der Kita
und bitte vermeiden Sie dann auch
insbesondere Kontakt zu den Menschen die
besonders vulnerabel sind also die alten
hochaltrigen und Menschen mit
Vorerkrankungen
diese Menschen brauchen nach wie vor
unsere Solidarität
drittens wenn Sie eine Risikogruppe
selber angehören dann besprechen Sie
bitte mit Ihrem Arzt und ihre Ärztin ob
antivirale Arzneimittel in Frage kommen
die gibt es ja sowohl für Kurve 19
paxlovic steht hier im Vordergrund als
auch für Grippe ob wir eigentlich
gesunden fittenmenschen gilt wenn sich
die Symptome verschlimmern dann wenden
Sie sich bitte auch an einen Arzt und
viertens das Robert-Koch-Institut
empfiehlt weiter in den Innenräume Maske
zu tragen um sich selbst und auch andere
für Infektionen zu schützen das gilt
natürlich vor allen Dingen dann wenn
viele Menschen auf engem Raum
zusammenkommen und bei Kontakt zu
Menschen aus Risikogruppen je mehr
Menschen Maske tragen desto effektiver
ist der Schutz
und fünftens achten Sie bitte auf ihren
Impfschutz es gibt eine Impfung gegen
covid 19 hat Herr Minister Lauterbach
sehr klar eben nochmals ausgeführt die
diese Impfung sind der beste Schutz vor
einem schweren Krankheitsverlauf und
meine Damen und Herren es gibt immer
eine Impfung gegen Grippe und sie können
diese beiden Impfungen gleichzeitig auch
verabreicht bekommen in der Arztpraxis
eine Kurve 19 Auffrischimpfung senkt das
Risiko für eine hostile Hospitalisierung
deutlich wir haben gerade gestern den
impfeffektivitätsbericht wieder online
gestellt da können Sie die Daten sehen
wir wissen inzwischen auch dass die
Auffrischimpfung auch nach über 6
Monaten immer noch eine hohe
Effektivität vor einem schweren 19
verlaufen zeigt und das sind Daten aus
unserem Land eine Grippeimpfung wird
besonders Menschen ab 60 chronisch
Kranken und Schwangeren empfohlen aber
auch alle anderen können sich gegen
Grippe impfen lassen das besprechen Sie
am besten mit Ihrem Hausarzt oder ihre
Hausärztin helfen sie Immunsystem mit
Atemwegsinfektion besser voranzukommen
viel Bewegung an der frischen Luft und
eine ausgewogene Ernährung stärken die
Abwehrkräfte diese Tipps helfen so gut
und gesund wie möglich durch den Herbst
und den Winter zu kommen sie finden uns
auch bei uns und auch bei der BZgA auf
unserer Website entsprechende Flyer
vielen Dank Herr Wieler wir kommen zu
ihren Fragen die erste Frage hat Frau
Spiekermann
Herr Minister lauterbach
ungsprozession erheblichen Widerstand
der Länder die sagen
wir werden das nicht vollständig
umsetzen es gibt ja ohnehin Probleme sei
es bürokratischer Natur oder auch sonst
was sagen sie dazu und die zweite Frage
wäre auch zur isolationspflicht David
gesagt also warum folgt Deutschland
nicht auch sage ich mal dem
österreichischen Modell und sagt man
kann auch weiterhin am
gesellschaftlichen Leben teilnehmen und
muss sich nicht isolieren also
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht und
isolationspflicht diese beiden Fragen
ja vielen Dank zur einrichtungsbezogenen
Impfpflicht wir kommen ja jetzt in eine
Situation hinein wo wir leider muss man
sagen eine Zunahme der schweren Verläufe
erwarten müssen und das auch in den
Pflegeeinrichtungen die impfen sind
angesprochen worden somit müssen die
Menschen die dort leben besonders
geschützt werden und bei denjenigen die
geimpft worden sind die vierte Impfung
schon haben ist zum Teil der Impfschutz
schon nicht mehr so stark wie er früher
gewesen ist daher also rechne ich damit
dass wir also in den Pflegeeinrichtungen
Schwierigkeiten bekommen werden da
müssen wir besonders vorsichtig sein das
gleiche gilt natürlich auch für
Krankenhäuser wenn immunsupprimierte
Menschen in Krankenhäusern behandelt
werden und infizieren sich dann eben
dort mit Corona Karussell gefährlich
werden zum Beispiel für
nierentransplantierte für Menschen mit
einer chronischen also Krebserkrankungen
mit einer Leukämie beispielsweise kann
andere Tumor sein aber auch bei
defekten gegeben beispielsweise
und da sollten diese Menschen gerade in
den medizinischen Einrichtungen
besonders geschützt sein und dazu trägt
die
einrichtungsbezogene eben Pflicht ganz
maßgeblich bei somit ist die
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht richtig
und wichtig und hat bestanden und ich
bedanke mich an dieser Stelle bei den
vielen Einrichtungen die das auch fast
komplett umgesetzt haben sind da sehr
viele Einrichtungen die es gemacht haben
zum zweiten also bei der
isolationspflicht ehrlich gesagt sehe
keinen Sinn darin dass wir das
Infektionsgeschehen jetzt noch befeuern
wir sehen ja schon stark steigende
Fahrzeiten wir haben jetzt leider weil
die Welle ja beginnt auch an den
Arbeitsplätzen aber auch also in den
Praxen haben wir eine deutliche Zunahme
der pfanzer und wenn wir auf
isolationspflicht verzichten würden
würde wäre geschehen ja nur beschleunigt
somit gibt es aus meiner Sicht keine
epidemiologischen Gründe dafür von der
isolationspflicht also hier
zurückzutreten sie ist immer sinnvoll
gewesen aber sie wird bei den hohen
Fallzahlen die wir jetzt erwarten müssen
um sie sinnvoller
Lauterbach mich würde interessieren was
ist aus ihrer Sicht noch mal wenn Sie
den wellenverlauf schon absehen können
der spät möglichste Zeitpunkt für die
Länder tatsächlich bei der maskenpflicht
in Innenräumen was zu tun und Sie
zufrieden sind Sie mit den Maßnahmen und
dem Problem Bewusstsein der Länder bis
jetzt
sehr gute Frage zunächst einmal was ich
typischerweise nicht tue dass ich also
öffentlich den Ländern von hier aus
Ratschläge geben was zu tun ist ich sage
das deshalb weil die Länder selbst zum
Teil ganz anders vorgehen ich bekomme ja
ständig Ratschläge über die
Öffentlichkeit von den Ländern zum
Beispiel vier unions also regierte
Länder
fordern mich hier so auf
isolationspflicht aufzugeben oder aus
Bayern zum Beispiel komme ich Vorschläge
dass das Infektionsschutzgesetz was
Osmane sich mit das strengste in Europa
ist aber da wurde dann vorgetragen das
müsste noch stärker sein also ich müsste
die FDP noch stärker heran nehmen ich
Vorschläge werden wir dann aber zum Teil
öffentlich vor also öffentlich
mitgeteilt wenn da wenn ich die gleichen
Protagonisten mit dem Maßkrug in der
Hand sehe und daher möchte ich mich
einfach nicht an dieser Art also
öffentliche ratgeberei beteiligen bitte
ich um Verständnis
was man sagen kann ist also die Länder
müssen es genau beobachten was jetzt
passiert ich rechne damit dass wir jetzt
eine Zeit lang wirklich nur mit dieser
ba5 Variante zu kämpfen haben andere
Varianten die kommen könnten sind noch
weit weg somit lässt sich das
Infektionsgeschehen schon einigermaßen
gut modulieren dazu haben wir jetzt auch
in dieser Woche im Expertenrat sehr
interessanter also Analysen gesehen
vorgetragen bekommen auch zum Beispiel
aus der Arbeitsgruppe von Frau
briesemann aber nicht nur von ihr und
also dieses Material und also diese
Berechnungen stehen natürlich auch den
Ländern zur Verfügung jederzeit es muss
der
soft-spot erreicht werden weil man am
besten einsteigt und da sind solche
Modellierungen Gold wert dann kann man
sehen also wie lange geht zu einer Welle
wann hätte sie zum Beispiel ihren
Höhepunkt ist das jetzt eine Welle die
sich meinetwegen in drei Wochen wieder
selbst begrenzt oder muss man mit mehr
rechnen wie lange wird es dauern bis man
wirklich hat uns weiter das kann man
alles relativ gut modellieren im Moment
weil wir also eine Sondersituation haben
wir haben zum einen also das gleiche
Geschehen in vielen Ländern gleichzeitig
hat ja eben ein paar Länder genannt
Niederlande Belgien England Dänemark
Frankreich überall kann man recht gut
also sehen was das geschehen ist also
eine Variante und zum zweiten eben also
wir haben mittlerweile auch mehr
Erfahrung mit der Modellierung gewonnen
und somit haben die Länder tatsächlich
alles was Sie benötigen um den Platz zu
finden die Maßnahmen zu ergreifen
ja also ich halte fest es gibt einen
richtigen Zeitpunkt nur ihre neue Rolle
verbietet was dazu zu sagen nein ich bin
nicht zuständig für alle Länder ich war
so bin jederzeit also auch mit den
Ländern bereit mich auszutauschen das
tun wir ja auch offen gesagt und ich
glaube das Länder das richtig machen
werden also ich glaube dass das was wir
jetzt in Bayern gesehen haben was ich
für falsch und nicht wirklich
verantwortungsvoll gehalten habe aber
dass das die Ausnahme ist das wird die
Ausnahme bleiben und ich glaube die
Länder werden sehr schnell sehen dass es
in ihrem Interesse ist das
Infektionsschutzgesetz so zu nutzen dass
eben die Überlastung nicht stattfindet
denn niemand will das ja wir wollen
einfach das Corona ein also Problem
bleibt was sozusagen im Hintergrund
läuft sich aber nicht in den Vordergrund
schiebt und das werden auch die Länder
nur erreichen wenn Sie das
Infektionsschutzgesetz gut einsetzen
zwei Fragen wieder viele infizite machen
ja mittlerweile keinen PCR-Test mehr
können Sie uns sagen wie hoch sie die
Dunkelziffer Einschätzen der Infizierten
und Herr Lauterbach stand heute sind
lediglich 76% der deutschen vollständig
geimpft
eine Viertel der Deutschen einfach
unbelehren
in den letzten Punkt bitte nochmal
sind ein Viertel der Deutschen einfach
unbelehrbar und belehrbar okay also ich
glaube dass die Dunkelziffer auf der
Grundlage dessen was wir bisher sehen
können in etwa
drei Mal so hoch ist das heißt dass wir
möglicherweise insgesamt viermal so
viele Fälle haben wir derzeit offiziell
ausweisen das ist meine persönliche
Einschätzung
hier spreche ich für eine Sekunde
wirklich nicht also als
also das ist mein epidempidemiologischer
Einschätzung dass wir also eine
dunkelzhilfe haben die größer ist als
die Dunkelziffer die wir früher gehabt
haben früher war die Dunkelziffer immer
60 Prozent also bis 100 Prozent also
doppelt so viele Fälle das ist jetzt
mehr und ich würde davon ausgehen dass
wir wahrscheinlich insgesamt also
nochmal dreimal so viele Fälle in der
Dunkelziffer haben wie in der
ausgewiesenen
Fallzahl weil eben so viele derzeit also
ich nicht über den PCR noch mal testen
lassen
dass die Dunkelziffer kann auch wieder
runter gehen übrigens und zwar dann wenn
beispielsweise also die Symptome
zunehmen und das ist im also Herzes hat
er wieder ja auch ausgeführt im Herbst
und im Winter verlaufen die gleichen
atemwegs Erkrankung auch häufig schwerer
und dann kann man zum Beispiel glauben
man hat eine Grippe lässt sich dann also
in der Praxis testen dann ist es doch
kurvig und so weiter somit die derzeit
noch relativ hohe Dunkelziffer kann
wieder zurückgehen aber das wäre mein
Abschätzung und die also vollständige
Impfung ja gut das ist halt so dass wir
hier Schwierigkeiten haben nicht desto
trotz wir werden eine Impfkampagne
nutzen und es ist auch so ich glaube
dass wir da noch also nochmals einiges
erreichen können viele haben geglaubt
dass die Pandemie quasi über den Sommer
endet viele haben gehört das ist also
nach dem Sommer vorbei es gab auch sehr
viel Berichterstattung die so etwas
nahegelegt hat oder es gab
wissenschaftliche gesagt haben das ist
also ab dem nächsten Herbst ist dass wir
eine Erkältung oder man soll sich sogar
seine Erkrankung also eine Infektion
abholen oder viele glauben weil schon so
viel infiziert waren dass man sich nicht
erneut infizieren können und so weiter
sind ja alles da mal Hoffnungen gewesen
aber diese Hoffnungen werden sich ja
nicht erfüllen und in dieser Hoffnung
sich nicht erfüllen dann wird das auch
viele erreichen die bisher sich nicht
haben impfen lassen die dann begreifen
okay es ist dann doch so es ist nicht
weg es kommt schon wieder der ganze
Herbst und Winter bis ins Frühjahr liegt
noch vor uns will ich das wirklich
tragen das Risiko es wird viele geben
die begreifen okay lonkovic ist
tatsächlich ein Problem also es ist kein
keine Einbildung da kann ich
schwererkrankung sein will ich das
wirklich es wird leben die dann also
plötzlich sehen okay jetzt gibt es
diejenigen die sind im Frühjahr
infiziert gewesen jetzt bekommen sie ist
schon wieder ich hatte das auch lass ich
mich hier impfen und so somit ich glaube
dass dieser Realismus es kommt zurück
und Impfungen helfen dazu führen wird
dass ein nicht unerheblicher Teil von
den 25 Prozent die wir nicht vollständig
impfen konnten bisher dass wir die noch
erreichen werden
Ergänzungen
Lauterbach einig dreimal so viel also
wir gehen davon aus dass die
Dunkelziffer momentan wirklich höher ist
als in dem Schnitt das heißt also wir
gehen auch davon aus dass mehr als
zweimal so hoch ist eher dreimal so hoch
in diesem Bereich schätzen wir das auch
ja
kurz vom deutschen Ärzte
Blatt für die Verhandlung mit der
Ärzteschaft für die kommenden Jahre
einzuspielen und die Fahndung
auszusetzen und ob das Platz im
gkv-finanzstabilisierungsgesetz finden
wird
ich persönlich also ich kann mich dieser
Forderung der Krankenkassen nicht
anschließen
weil ich also dafür auch keine also
gute Begründung sehe auch die Praxen
haben ja mit den inflations und mit
steigenden Energiekosten zu kämpfen und
also ein solches
Opfer der niedergelassenen Kolleginnen
und Kollegen kann ich nicht
nachvollziehen
da sie eben sich beide kritisch geäußert
haben über die so hoch gestiegene
Dunkelziffer das ist ja zum Teil auch
Produkt ihrer politischen Entscheidungen
durch den Wegfall der kostenlosen
PCR-Test wird weniger getestet und das
haben sie eben selbst als eine Grundlage
für die Dunkelziffer genannt war es das
wert
nein das ist zunächst einmal nicht
richtig also der PCR-Test wenn ich zum
Arzt gehe ist kostenlos
sie machen wahrscheinlich den
antigen-test oder was meinst ja ich war
sie haben Recht man den antigentest der
aber in aller Regel sozusagen die
Vorlage den Anlass dann für den
kostenlosen PCR-Test gegeben hat also
zunächst einmal die antigen-test werden
ja für diejenigen die also entsprechende
Indikationen haben die Menschen betreuen
die krank sind oder in Krankenhäuser
müssen die Pflegeeinrichtungen werden ja
weiter kostenlos angeboten und diese
Schutzgebühr von 3 Euro wird es häufig
nicht genommen aber selbst dort wo sie
genommen wird werden die bürgertest nach
wie vor durchgeführt und die
Dunkelziffer ist darauf aus meiner Sicht
nicht zurückzuführen die Dunkelziffer
betrifft ja diejenigen die den
antigen-test gemacht haben aber dann den
PCR-Test nicht machen man hätte sogar
davon ausgehen können dass die Zahl der
positiven steigt wenn der also an die
Gentest also demnächst bezahlt werden
muss und ich bekomme beim 18 PCR-Test
umsonst das ist aber auch nicht der Fall
gewesen somit da muss man vorsichtig
sein Spekulationen es waren nicht leicht
bei der derzeitigen Finanzlage die also
bürgertest in dem Umfang wie wir diese
Tests in Deutschland machen weiter
anzubieten das tun wir aber und es ist
auch richtig zu sagen mir ist kein
einziges europäisches Land bekannt wo
die bürgertests noch so flächendeckend
angeboten und genutzt werden wie
Deutschland
ich habe eine Zusatzfrage zur einricht
zu den einrichtungsbezogenen Maßnahmen
neben der Impfpflicht gibt es ja die
maskenpflicht da sagen jetzt
Patientenorganisationen die Formulierung
das auf Masken nur verzichtet werden
dürfe bei Aufenthalt in den dauerhaft
dafür vorgesehenen Räumen würde bedeuten
dass eigentlich auch die Bewohner von
Heimen
im Grunde nur in ihren Zimmern die Maske
ablegen dürfen ist das gemeint mit
dieser Formulierung bedeutet es dass
Bewohner von alten und Pflegeheimen
tatsächlich nur wenn sie sich in ihren
Zimmern aufhalten die Maske ablegen
dürfen das wird von vielen
Organisationen als nicht menschenwürdige
Situation bezeichnet
also zunächst einmal ist es richtig dass
in den Pflegeeinrichtungen die Maske so
viel wie möglich getragen werden sollte
zumindest ist das sehr wichtig solange
wir noch diese Impflücken haben und es
kommt eben sehr darauf an wie die also
Situationen in den Einrichtungen ist das
muss man sich selbst überlegen wenn
beispielsweise in einem
Gemeinschaftsraum 50 zu pflegende sitzen
und keiner hat die Maske an dann würde
ich das für sehr riskant halten das muss
man sich also wirklich vor Augen führen
also die selbst bei relativ guten also
Test Routinen muss man sich wirklich gut
vor Augen führen also es sei denn wir
haben wirklich eine Impfquote in den
Einrichtungen die so gut ist dass man
also Infektionen in Kauf nehmen kann
aber wir haben ja dann nach wie vor also
im Flug und diese Impflücken sind
zweierlei wir haben eine Gruppe die ist
noch gar nicht zum also vierten Mal
geimpft und wir haben diejenigen da ist
die vierte Impfung schon sehr lange
zurück liegt sie sehr lange zurück das
heißt wir haben wahrscheinlich dann bei
vielen Pflegebedürftigen also haben wir
eine Situation dass wir erhebliche
Impflücken haben und wenn dann in einem
Gemeinschaftsraum Tag für Tag gemeinsam
30 40 Leute zusammensetzen ist das
Risiko einfach sehr sehr hoch und das
muss man zu Ende denken da muss man wenn
man sagt also was will man nicht die
sind Schutz will man nicht muss man auch
klar sagen dann werden wir dort
erhebliche
Belastungen sehen dann werden wir auch
also dann werden wir leider muss man
sagen sehr viele Tote sehen
wir machen in der Mitarbeiter
Herr Minister sie haben ja
öfter schon betont dass den mit der
deutschen Gesetzesgrundlage man sagen
die strengsten jetzt im Ländervergleich
habe sind wir in Deutschland einfach
schlauer als andere das wäre eine Frage
an Sie und an Herrn Wieler sie hatten ja
gesagt dass es ist gerade deutlich mehr
Atemwegsinfektionen gibt als in früheren
Jahren ist da auch ein Nachholeffekt
dabei weil im vorigen Jahr sich halt
viele Menschen Maske und Abstand
geschützt haben
also Deutschland ist nicht schlauer
sondern vorsichtiger wir sind ja auch
gemessen an der Gesamtzahl der Menschen
die bisher an kovid gestorben sind sind
wir
relativ gut durch die Pandemie bisher
gekommen wir haben halt also relativ
vorsichtige Maßnahmen gemacht und die
Bevölkerung hat sie auch gerne befolgt
somit haben wir tatsächlich wenn man von
einer kleinen Gruppe mal absieht die
sich sehr laut artikuliert haben wir
eine breite Unterstützung der Maßnahmen
immer gehabt die werden wir im Herbst
auch wieder haben wenn die Menschen
sehen das ist wieder notwendig im
übrigen sind das ja nur Möglichkeiten es
kommt es ja wirklich darauf an dass die
Länder die Möglichkeiten auch nutzen
noch haben wir diese Leistung nicht
abgerufen aber tatsächlich also wollen
wir hier verhindern dass wir eine
Überlastung des Gesundheitssystems haben
der kritischen Infrastruktur auch die
damit einhergehenden erheblichen
ökonomischen Verluste ich bitte Sie zu
beachten also jetzt wird ja sehr viel
darüber gesprochen dass eine Rezession
kommt davon gehe auch ich aus aber
natürlich fällt die Rezession umso übler
aus je mehr Einbrüche wir haben am wenn
zum Beispiel Lieferketten einbrechen
wenn also bestimmte Infrastrukturen
nicht mehr vorgehalten werden kann wenn
also die Produktion einsinkt das ist
ganz klar also das ist auch also ein
sehr negative Auswirkungen auf die
Rezession haben kann wenn wir hier
massive Ausfälle bei den Beschäftigten
haben somit wir sind vorsichtig gewesen
ich hoffe wir werden es erneut sein und
jedes Land hat er seinen eigenen Weg da
muss da kann man keine anderen Länder
kritisieren wir haben aber eine
besonders schwere also Herausforderung
in diesem Herbst und im Winter wegen der
Gaskrise und ich will einfach dass wir
gut verstanden wird wir wollen erreichen
dass die corona-krise noch dass die
nicht die Gaskrise noch verschlimmert
indem wir massenhaft Ausfall an den
Arbeitsplätzen haben wir haben keine
belegbaren Betten mehr und dergleichen
das muss einfach vermieden werden das
können wir vermeiden
ich habe die Frage von der Villa richtig
also es gibt eine Reihe von Gründen die
womit wir das erklären es gibt
tatsächlich Hinweise dass es auch ein
Nachholeffekt sein kann wir haben so
effektiv geschützt in den letzten zwei
Jahren und es ist möglich dass
tatsächlich hier eine gewisse
immunitätslücke entstanden ist dass muss
man im
Gesamtkontext sehen dass wir in
Deutschland ja eine der ältesten
Population der Welt haben wir haben eine
Demografie wo wir sehr sehr viele
Menschen haben die alt hochaltrig sind
und auch eben teilweise eine Reihe von
Grundkrankheiten haben und insofern ist
dieser Effekt ein ein Effekt der
der dazu geführte dass er viele
Menschenleben haben retten können und
was ich denke wir immer noch vor Augen
haben müssten das habe ich auch noch mal
in meinen Eingangsstatement gesagt wir
können ja nach wie vor Masken einsetzen
und wir sehen ja dass viele Menschen
diese Masken auch im privaten Bereich
einsetzen weil sie eben wissen dass sie
dadurch das Risiko Infektionen
weiterzugeben reduzieren und darum ist
sind diese Maßnahmen weiter wichtig und
in einem hohen Maße
werden sie dazu führen das war die
Krankheitslast eben auch in diesem
Winter wieder absenken können
sie haben jetzt vorhin wieder erzählt
warum sie die vierte Impfung so wichtig
halten und dafür geworben machen das an
vielen Stellen für Interviews haben wir
es auch bei Twitter gemacht und haben da
geschrieben dass ich Menschen die
Infektion durch neue Impfung ersparen
können also nicht weniger Risiko oder
weniger Möglichkeit sondern ersparen
nicht bekommen auf welche
wissenschaftliche Grundlage stützen Sie
diese Behauptung ganz konkret welche
Studie oder wie auch immer wo kommt die
Behauptung her dass die vierte Impfung
die Infektion verhindert und dann sicher
wieder ich wollte mich ähnliche Frage
stellen wie der Kollege eben gerade sie
haben davon vorhin von den von der
erhöhten Zahl der anderen Erkrankungen
gesprochen die jetzt mehr als Mehrwert
haben eben gerade noch gesagt das war
ein jüngere Menschen betroffen sind das
hat er mit der Krankheitslast der
Bevölkerung dann im gesamten nichts zu
tun was bringt also dass erneute
einsetzen an vielen Orten von Maske wenn
wir in die vergangenen Jahren durch das
erhöhte Einsetzen von Maske
immunitätslücken hergestellt haben
gerade bei jungen Menschen
zunächst einmal vielen Dank die Frage
ist ja die ist es plausibel zu glauben
dass also angepasste Impfstoffe wie zum
Beispiel bieberländer ba5 Impfstoff dass
der auch dazu beiträgt dass weniger
Menschen sich infizieren oder ist es so
dass man diesen Impfstoff beispielsweise
jetzt applizieren könnte und das
Infektionsrisiko singt gar nicht das
wäre auch denkbar aber ich kenne ehrlich
gesagt kein Wissenschaftler der ist so
argumentieren würde weil wir haben
natürlich bisher immer gesehen dass die
also an dass der Anstieg der
neutralisierenden Antikörper gegen die
Variante die gerade kursiert gut
korreliert mit der Schutzwirkung vor
Ansteckung das ist nie perfekt aber es
wird das haben wir sogar da gesehen wo
es nicht genau die Variante gewesen ist
für die man impft beispielsweise an
zentralen Impfstoff nutze ich und schaue
dann also wie also geht wie verändert
sich das Risiko sich anzustecken bei
beispielsweise
dann sieht man dort eine Senkung der
Wahrscheinlichkeit sich anzustecken
durch die schlechte Nachricht ist halt
es wird nicht so lange und es wirklich
perfekt aber wenn der Impfstoff genau
auf die Variante passt die also
hier also angezielt wird dann also
korrelieren die
Täter der angepassten Impfstoffe mit dem
Infektionsschutz ganz gut zumindest wenn
Sie also vierstellig sind und aufhört
zum dafür gibt es viele Studien
bei ba5 angepassten Impfstoff gibt es da
noch keine Studien bei Menschen gibt es
tierexperte Studien die sind auch die
Grundlage für die Zulassung übrigens der
Impfstoffe gewesen und die bekommen wir
natürlich also vorgetragen und
besprechen die auch mit den also
Herstellern dieser Impfstoffe aber auch
mit unabhängigen Wissenschaftlern wir
haben zum Beispiel auch in Expertenrat
in dieser Woche noch mal darüber
gesprochen also wie hoch die
Schutzwirkungen gegen Ansteckung
wahrscheinlich ist bei ba5 Impfstoff in
Bezug auf den Schutz vor also der ba5
Variante die derzeit kursiert und man
kann sich auch also schon damit
beschäftigen wie wird eigentlich ein
solcher Impfstoff vor Ansteckung
schützen bei der Beko 1.1 feiern doch
dazu gibt es bereits Studien aber ich
will einfach um Verständnis also ich
kann das hier nicht ausufern lassen in
ein Seminar über also die Art und Weise
wie neutralisierende Antikörper mit dem
Infektionsschutz korrelieren vielleicht
will Kollege Wähler dort also ergänzen
und ich würde oder oder
assistieren lassen Sie doch den Minister
erstmal Ausreden das wird doch nicht
bevor sie ins Wort gehen
wieder hier assistieren aber
grundsätzlich ist es so also es wäre man
kann keinen perfekten Schutz vor
Infektionen erwarten das ist ganz klar
aber wir rechnen natürlich mit einem
auch Infektionsschutz im Vordergrund
steht natürlich Mieterschutz vor
schwerer Krankheit jetzt ist er wieder
dran
ja also zunächst einmal ist es natürlich
eine temporäre Betrachtung das ist
natürlich so wenn man kurz nach der
Impfung hat man natürlich auch einen
höheren Schutz vor Infektion der lässt
aber schnell nach aber das wesentliche
Ziel dieser Impfungen ist dass wir
Menschen vor einem schweren Erkrankungen
vor dem Tod schützen wollen und das
dass das ist auch mit solchen
Impfstoffen im Mittelpunkt sie wissen
vielleicht es gibt ja auch Diskussionen
darüber und das heißt die Diskussion es
gibt ja Forschungsrichtungen wo man sich
mit Impfstoffen befasst die zum Beispiel
einer Saal appliziert werden die dann
einen höheren Schutz vor der Infektion
geben und diesen Impfstoff in den
möchten wir natürlich auch zur Verfügung
haben da wird auch dran gearbeitet aber
wie gesagt
diese Impfstoffe vermitteln eben in
erster Linie ein hoher risiko-reduktion
für hohe für schwere Krankheiten und für
Tod das muss man immer wissen das ist ja
auch der Grund und auch die lässt ja
nach mit der Zeit und darum machen wir
ständig diesen impfmonitoring Bericht um
die zeiträum einzuschätzen wir haben
glaube ich gestern wenn ich das richtige
im Kopf habe noch mal berechnet die
imperfektivitäten in Deutschland das bei
den bis zu 60-Jährigen immer noch in
mehr nach sechs Monaten immer noch rund
60 65 Prozent Schutz vor schwerer
Erkrankungen ist bei den hochaltrigen
sogar 80 Prozent ja also gerade die die
er das größte Risiko tragen das steht im
Vordergrund zu dem Nachholeffekt ich
möchte das noch mal klar sagen man hat
bei allen Maßnahmen natürlich an
bestimmten trade-off ja diese Maßnahmen
sind nie perfekt sie wirken auch nie zu
100 Prozent aber sie reduzieren eben ein
bestimmtes Risiko und man sieht und ist
zwischen gibt es ja auch genügend
Publikationen darüber dass du durch die
Maßnahmen eben wirklich Menschenleben
gerettet wurden und Infektionszahlen
reduziert wurden und die ganze Zeit
haben wir in Deutschland das ist auch in
allen anderen Ländern gemacht worden im
Ziel gehabt möglichst viele
Krankheitsfälle zu verhindern möglichst
viele Todesfälle zu verhindern und
möglichst die
überlastungsgesundheitssystem zu
verändern jetzt in der stabilen Lage wo
wir jetzt sind werden diese Masken ja
auch nicht mehr so konsequent eingesetzt
ich gehe auch nicht davon aus dass wir
zum Beispiel Schulen von Ländern die die
Schließung von Schulen angeordnet wird
ich kann das nicht ausschließen aber ich
gehe mal davon aus das heißt also dass
dann auch dadurch wieder eine gemäßigte
Infektionsdruck auch wieder kommt die
Masken reduzieren ja nur das Risiko aber
sie reduzieren das natürlich nie auf
100%, ich kann Ihnen garantieren dass
auch in den letzten beiden Jahren Kinder
infiziert wurden mit diesen normalen
atemwegserregern
Nachfrage ich würde gerne einfach die
Aussage von Lauterbach zusammenfassen
also das heißt die Stützen diese Aussage
ob Plausibilität oder Erfahrung und
nicht auf aktuelle Studien
nein das habe ich wieder gesagt noch ich
glaube seit jeder was ich gesagt habe
hat glaube ich jeder verstanden von
daher das wie sie es zusammengefasst
haben ist es nicht richtig und mich das
nicht noch einmal also
die die Studienlage ist die dass wir im
Tierexperiment und auch bei also den
Impfstoffen die wir bisher genutzt haben
immer gesehen haben dass die
neutralisierenden antikörpertitel
korreliert haben mit dem Schutz vor
Infektionen
genau wie er wie das gerade beschrieben
hat das ist immer die Frage wie lange
ist der Schutz aber man hat eine gewisse
Zeit lang also Schutz vor der Infektion
das kann man approximieren oder konnte
man in den Studien immer aboximieren
durch die also Höhe der also
Varianten spezifischen neutralisierenden
antikörpertitel wenn diese über 1000
lagen oder darüber gibt es halt sehr
viele Studien und somit also ist alles
dazu gesagt
Frau Spiekermann
Herr Professor Wiener ich habe eine
frage zum wir haben es viel auch über
Dunkelziffern gesprochen zum
immunitätsstatus der Bevölkerung wo
liegt der denn weil der war ja mal auch
in den vergangenen Jahren sehr wichtig
um bestimmte Maßnahmen zurechtfertigen
das ist nicht einfach zu sagen also
warum ist das nicht einfach zu sagen es
gibt dafür zwei Gründe
wir kennen keinen Wert den wir im Labor
bestimmen können mit dem wir sagen diese
Person hatten Schutz oder diese Person
hat keinen Schutz es gibt auch noch
anderthalb Jahren intensiver Forschung
noch kein Laborparameter mit dem Sie das
sagen können sie können
Antikörpertiter bestimmen und Sie können
auch dann in der Zellkultur im Labor
bestimmen dass man mit diesen
Antikörpern bestimmte viruslasten
reduzieren können aber es gibt keinen
Grenzwert das ist ein ganz wichtiger
Punkt
dass das es muss auch immer wieder in
den Köpfen der Leute sein so das heißt
also es korrelieren hohe Antikörpertiter
auch zwingend mit gutem Schutz es gibt
auch Menschen die haben ganz niedrige
antikörpertitel aber wenn man dann eine
Infektion hat und sie dann nachverfolgt
haben die trotzdem Schutz es gibt die
t-zellimmunität und die können wir
einfach im Labor nicht gut messen das
ist das eine darum ist es schwer zu
sagen wie die Immunitätslage ist das
zweite ist
natürlich wissen wir nicht welche von
für jeden einzelnen Menschen wie oft er
geimpft wurde womit er geimpft wurde und
wie viel Infektionen er hatte das heißt
da gibt es einfach eine große
Variabilität und darum ist es relativ
schwierig das zu sagen was wir wissen
ist das was wir publizieren dass wir
sagen dass eine bestimmte Zeitraum ist
ein bestimmter Prozentsatz der der Leute
die zwei Impfung haben haben eben noch
eine hohe impfschutzwirkung das können
wir sagen aber wie viel Menschen das
genau sind das können wir aus folgenden
Gründen nicht sagen wir erhalten ja von
der KBV nur aggregierte Daten das habe
ich schon mehrfach erläutert also
aggregierte Daten heißt wir halten
Starten von Menschen die unter
19 sind also
fünf Jahre bis 19 oder 12 bis 19 wir
halten Daten von Kindern die von
Erwachsenen bis zu 59 Jahre alt sind und
von denen die über 60 Jahre alt sind das
heißt wir haben hier nur aggregierte
Daten wir haben keine
einzelfallbasierten Daten und darum
können wir das nicht so genau sagen
Herr Professor wieder davon ausgehen
können dass mich das natürlich jetzt
nicht zufrieden stellt weil
wie gesagt diese immunitätsstatus war
immer Richtwert für das was an Maßnahmen
ergriffen wurde und jetzt sagen Sie es
gibt eigentlich keine zuverlässigen
Daten man müsste doch wissen also wie
die Impfrate ist wie die genesenen Rates
und daraus Rückschlüsse zu ziehen wie
sicher die Bevölkerung ist ich habe sie
ja gerade erklärt ich also zum einen
habe ich nicht ganz verstanden ja tut
mir leid wenn ich schlecht erklärt habe
noch mal wir haben doch es gibt ein
Report hier steht es drin impfgeschehen
in Deutschland dieser Report ist online
den kann jeder lesen in publizieren wir
alle vier Wochen und doch steht drin wie
Effekt wie effektiv die Impfung ist das
heißt also wir können sagen wenn
Menschen ab einem bestimmten Zeitung wie
oft sie geimpft werden wissen wir mit
einer statistischen Wahrscheinlichkeit
dass sie eine 80 prozentige
Wahrscheinlichkeit haben nicht mehr
schwer
aber wir wissen nicht genau wie das für
jeden einzelnen Menschen in Deutschland
ist wir wissen nicht genau wann jeder
Mensch geimpft wurde wie lange der
Zeitraum ist das heißt wir schätzen das
schätzen das so ab und der Einzelne muss
halt wissen hat der seiner eigenen
investorie wie hoch sein Impfschutz ist
wenn er eben vor mehr als sechs Monaten
zum letzten Mal geimpft worden war dann
fällt sein Impfschutz ab
ergänze nämlich da ja also wir das
beschrieben hat ist eigentlich was weiß
ich also auch seit längerem auch immer
wieder vorgetragen haben das gibt ja
diese Illusion wir machen jetzt eine
Blutuntersuchung in der Bevölkerung und
sehen dann wie es die also wir sind die
Antikörper und dann können wir sagen wo
stehen wir jetzt also der kann sich noch
infizieren wie viele können sterben das
kann natürlich nie funktionieren weil
also ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht
welche Antikörper sind das sind das
Antikörper gegen Varianten die wir
längst nicht mehr haben sind die anderen
Teile die wir also in Blut haben die von
Viren quasi abgeleitet werden sind das
sogenannte nukleokapsid wie viel ist
davon das wird gar nicht gemessen dann
kommt es darauf an also
wie sind das jetzt Antikörper die durch
Impfungen gekommen sind oder sind die
durch also Infektion gekommen das kann
ich sehr schlecht unterscheiden das geht
nur durch Spezialuntersuchung und da
muss man sich dann eben in der
Gesamtschau heran tasten ich sag mal
etwas positives was viele nicht wissen
dürften aber was also sehr wichtig ist
was wir zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt sehen ich
hoffe einfach dass das so bleibt ihr
seht wir wissen dass also da mal
diejenigen die an ba1 und bh2 infiziert
waren Omegon weil dass sie sich sehr
leicht an ba5 infizieren können die
haben so gut wie keinen Schutz
oder sehr wenig Schutz ganz wenig Schutz
weniger 20 Prozent aber diejenigen die
ba5 schon mal hatten da sehen wir bisher
kaum reinflexionen das heißt es scheint
sozusagen dass der die Stadt gab der
ba5-infektion bisher zumindest vor einer
weiteren ba5-infektion sehr gut schützt
wieso ist das relevant wieso ist das
überhaupt wichtig das lässt vermuten
dass auch die Impfung gegen ba5 gut
gegen die Infektion von ba5 schützt weil
ich die gleichen Mechanismus quasi habe
ich auch quasi die Antikörper die
geschaffen werden bei der Idee A5
Infektion und die schaffe ich auch durch
die ba5 Impfung und daher ist die
Hoffnung D und beim im Labor haben wir
das schon gesehen im Labor haben wir das
gesehen es gibt eben noch keine ba5
Studien also in beim Menschen in der
Größenordnung wo das gezeigt werden
könnte weil wir sonst Impfstoffe so
schnell nicht dessen zulassen können
aber im Labor haben wir das gesehen dass
die ba5 Impfstoffe sehr gut schützen
wenn ich jetzt vergleiche hoch geht denn
der Antikörper bei ba5 Impfungen im
Vergleich zu einem Impfstoff meinetwegen
und Anzahl alter Impfstoff dann ist der
Faktor zwischen 5 bis 20 das heißt ich
habe fünf bis zwanzig Mal so viele
Antikörper gegen ba5 wenn ich mit ba5
impfe im Vergleich zur der alten Impfung
und das ist worauf wir setzen was unsere
Hoffnung ist das ist der Punkt wo wir
glauben dass wir dort also durchbringen
es ist das nicht eine Hoffnung die der
Leier hat sondern das ist die Hoffnung
der Wissenschaftler die Wissenschaftler
die diese Impfstoffe entwickelt haben
oder die meinetwegen diese Impfstoffe
empfehlen oder damit die Studien machen
ich bin wirklich mit den
Wissenschaftlern in dieser Hinsicht
weltweit im Austausch wir haben da den
Expertenrat ich habe eben schon darüber
gesprochen wir haben uns diese Woche
darüber unterhalten aber ich und bin
diesbezüglich auch mit Wissenschaftlern
weltweit im Austausch und da ist halt
die der da ist halt
begründet der Hoffnung dass wir durch
die Impfung tatsächlich hier viel
erreichen können
ja wieder erst eine in der gemeinsamen
Finanz- und Haushaltspolitik nach 2024
aussehen soll ob Europa dauerhaft zu
einem realistischen Weg solider
Haushaltspolitik zurückkehren soll oder
ob wir zunehmend den Weg zu weiterer
Verschuldung gehen mit allen
Konsequenzen die das für die Stabilität
der Währungsunion und damit für den
Zusammenhang in Europa hat und das meine
Damen und Herren gilt umso mehr und gilt
umso mehr denn je heute weil die
Diskussion um die Reform des
stabi-paktes nächste Woche starten wird
mit den Vorschlägen der Europäischen
Kommission und es ist entscheidend dass
Deutschland in dieser Diskussion eine
konstruktive Führungsrolle einnimmt dass
wir uns mit Vorschlägen dass die
Bundesregierung sich mit Vorschlägen
einbringt mit denen wir nach Italien mit
denen wir nach Osteuropa die Perspektive
des Signal senden wie wir die
Währungsunion weiterentwickeln wollen
und wie wir zeigen wollen dass das es
geht so wurden im Blick auf Solidität
als auch mit Blick auf Realismus und
darum hätte ich mir gewünscht dass es
die Bundesregierung ist die diese
Diskussion ins Parlament bringt dass Sie
Ihre Vorstellungen hier im Plenum mit
den Parteien der Opposition auch
diskutieren bis heute haben sie das
nicht getan und darum haben wir das
heute auf die Tagesordnung gesetzt und
dass sie dieses Thema nicht ins
Parlament gebracht haben ist umso
erstaunlicher dass sie diese Diskussion
ja durchaus innerhalb ihrer Koalition
geführt haben und daraus ja dann auch
ihr Prinzipien Papier als
Verhandlungsgrundlage auf europäischer
Ebene entstanden ist und ich will an
dieser Stelle ausdrücklich sagen ihr
Papier enthält Elemente bei denen die
Richtung im Grundsatz auch erstmal
stimmt aber es zeigt sich dann leider
auch hier das Muster was ich so ein
bisschen durch die gesamte Finanzpolitik
ihrer Koalition zieht nämlich dass die
Ansätze im Finanzministerium erstmal die
richtige Richtung gehen und es dann
genau so lange hält bis sie damit zu
einer abgestimmten Position in der
Koalition kommen müssen und sie dann
immer entscheidenden Punkt falsch
abbiegen und
darum schreiben Sie auch in Ihren
Vorstellungen zur Reform des stabi-tages
erst mal gute Ansätze auf und biegen
dann aber eben gerade an der
entscheidenden Stelle falsch ab anstatt
den präventiven Arm zu stärken richtiger
Ansatz schaffen sie im Gegenzug oder
wollen Sie im Gegenzug die
Verpflichtungen zum verbindlichen
Schuldenabbau Kollegen Schäfer hat es
eben noch mal bestätigt abschaffen
anstatt durch einen insgesamt stärkeren
Fokus auf die ausgaberegelt die Regel
durchsetzbarer zu machen schlagen Sie
zusätzliche Ausnahmen zusätzliche
flexibilitätsklauseln zu machen das
Regelwerk damit nur noch komplizierter
und dann steigt die Verfahren bei
Regelverstößen zu verschlanken gibt es
überhaupt keine Vorschläge wie die
Verfahren besser und effektiver werden
sollen darum muss man leider sagen auch
wenn die Ansätze des Finanzministers
erstmal in die richtige Richtung weisen
Formel Kompromiss bei dem sie auch hier
mit ihren Koalitionspartnern Enden
verwässert im Ergebnis die europäischen
Schuldenregeln macht sie noch komplexer
und damit noch weniger durchsetzbar als
sie heute sind und darum machen wir
Ihnen mit unserem Antrag konkrete
Vorschläge zu welchen Schlussfolgerungen
sie in ihrem Papier eigentlich hätten
kommen müssen wie man statt die Regel
zum Schuldenabbau außer Kraft zu setzen
den Abbaupfad realistischer ausgestalten
kann und damit gerade nach Italien
beispielsweise das Signal setzen kann
das Realismus und Solidität zusammen
gehen wie man ganz konkret die Verfahren
verschlanken und straffen kann und damit
durchsetzbarer macht wie man die
Transparenz ob die Regel eingehalten
werden verbessern kann ein herzlicher
Appell insbesondere die Kollegin und
Kollegen der FDP lautet darum sorgen Sie
dafür dass bei der Reform der
europäischen Fiskalregeln nicht nur die
finanzpolitischen Ansätze stimmen
sondern ausnahmsweise auch mal das
Ergebnis die passenden Vorschläge dazu
liegen jetzt vor
der Bundestag diskutiert einen
unionsantrag für skalpolitische
Disziplinen in Europa lautet er und der
nächste Redner ist Johannes Schraps für
die SPD-Fraktion ist Mitglied im
Ausschuss für die Angelegenheiten der
Europäischen Union
verehrte Frau Präsidentin Liebe
schriftführerinnen und Schriftführer
sehr geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
sie sind in der Tat gerade mal etwas
mehr als ein Jahr her verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union da
haben wir tatsächlich noch in der
gemeinsamen Koalition regiert vor knapp
fünf Jahren haben wir den damaligen
Koalitionsvertrag ausgearbeitet und
seine Bestandteile anschließend Schritt
für Schritt umgesetzt und gerade das
bereits erwähnte europakapitel das war
damals maßgeblich wir haben uns damals
dazu bekannt dass der stabilitäts- und
Wachstumspakt auch in Zukunft unser
Kompass bleiben soll Stabilität und
Wachstum bedingen einander und bilden
eine Einheit so hieß es damals im
Koalitionsvertrag und wir waren uns
einig gemeinsam dafür einzutreten dass
Deutschland seine europäische
Verantwortung in einem Geist
partnerschaftlicher Zusammenarbeit und
gegenseitiger Solidarität gerecht wird
Deutschland hat Europa unendlich viel zu
verdanken und auch deshalb sind wir
seinem Erfolg verpflichtet
in Deutschland ist ein starkes und
geeintes Europa der beste Garant für
eine gute Zukunft in Frieden Freiheit
und Wohlstand verehrte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Bettina Hagedorn hat es zitiert
denn das ist der Koalitionsvertrag von
2018 und auch wir in der aktuellen
Koalition wollen weiter ein starkes und
stabiles Europa und insbesondere jetzt
wo zum ersten Mal seit Jahrzehnten
wieder ein brutaler Angriffskrieg auf
dem europäischen Kontinent stattfindet
da brauchen wir dieses Europa mehr denn
je verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
aber ich frage sie Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Union kann man ein
starkes und stabiles Europa
weiterentwickeln und weiter verbessern
oder wir sprechen ja über ein
unionsantrag ich sollte mich da
vielleicht etwas weniger progressiv
ausdrücken kann man ein starkes und
stabiles Europa bewahren indem man die
EU-Mitgliedsstaaten ohne finanzielle
Unterstützung und jegliche Stabilität in
einer Energie- und Wirtschaftskrise
einfach so dastehen lässt ich sag's mal
so es ist ja auch schon angesprochen
worden das konservative Krisenmanagement
der Austeritätspolitik hat in der
Europäischen Union nicht immer zu mehr
Zusammenhalt zu Stabilität und zur
Eindämmung von Krisen geführt weil
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
eine März 2020 da haben wir damals
übrigens auch noch in einer gemeinsamen
Koalition die allgemeine ausweichklausel
des
stabilitäts-staaten damit möglich war
durch kreditfinanzierte zusätzliche
Ausgaben ihre Volkswirtschaften in der
Krise zu stabilisieren das ist ja
deshalb offensichtlich unstrittig und
nun stellen sie auch fest dass diese
Ausnahme als Reaktion auf die
wirtschaftlichen Folgen des
ukrainekrieges von der EU-Kommission um
ein weiteres Jahr bis 2023 verlängert
wurde sie kritisieren das indem Sie
feststellen dass der stabilitäts- und
Wachstumspakt damit seit fast vier
Jahren außer Kraft gesetzt sei und
fordern in den bestehenden fiskalischen
regelrahmen zurückzukehren und die
ausweichklausel zu deaktivieren ich darf
das noch mal versuchen in etwas
einfachere Sprache zu übersetzen also
sie stellen fest dass die Möglichkeiten
dieser ausweichklausel vielen Ländern
und der Europäischen Union insgesamt
geholfen haben sich in einer akuten
Krisensituation zu stabilisieren und
haben das ja als Teil der vorherigen
Koalition richtigerweise mitgetragen und
heute mit diesem Antrag wollen sie in
einer Situation wo wir es sogar mit
multiple in Krisensituationen zu tun
haben das was damals funktioniert hat in
dem es stabilisierend gewirkt hat so
schnell wie möglich nicht mehr machen
und lieber wieder auf das Pferd setzen
das schon früher nicht so richtig etwas
gebracht hat ich weiß ja nicht so recht
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und Kollege Kollege liebt von der FDP
hat es angesprochen auch ich kann in
ihrem Antrag ehrlich gesagt keinerlei
konkrete Lösungsvorschläge erkennen wie
die EU-Mitgliedstaaten bei dann wieder
strengeren Vorschriften in der akuten in
der aktuellen akuten Krisenlage für
finanzielle Stabilität sorgen könnten
einige wirtschaftlich starke Länder in
Klammern Deutschland könnten das
möglicherweise hinbekommen
Klammern andere aber möglicherweise auch
nicht und ich sag mal zumindest und mit
dem Geist der partnerschaftlichen
Zusammenarbeit und mit der der
gegenseitigen Solidarität aus dem
Koalitionsvertrag von 2018 zu dem sie
sich damals bekannt haben kann ich ihre
Forderungen jetzt eben nicht mehr
verbinden und das ist schade das zu
hören dabei will ich gar nicht
bestreiten dass der stabilitäts- und
Wachstumspakt reformiert und
weiterentwickelt werden muss das ist
wenn ich es in ihrem Antrag richtig lese
ja auch bei ihnen Konsens und wenn man
sich die Geschichte seit der Einführung
des stabi-paktes vor knapp 30 Jahren so
anschaut dann muss man ja tatsächlich
feststellen die maastrichterkriterien
sind nicht immer eingehalten worden in
den Jahren nach der Staatsschulden und
Eurokrise da fand in vielen
Mitgliedsstaaten der Europäischen Union
zwar eine fiskalische Konsolidierung
statt nun im Angesicht der Kurve 19
Pandemie und der Inanspruchnahme von
massiven fiskalischen Konjunktur
Investitionsprogramm sind zahlreiche
Mitgliedsstaaten aber teilweise erneut
weit entfernt von der Einhaltung der EU
festkahl Regeln Reformbedarf ist also in
der Tat klar die Europäische Union hat
das aber ja offensichtlich auf dem
Schirm denn mit ihrer Mitteilung aus dem
vergangenen Oktober hat sie ja eine
Reform des
stabilitäts-staaten und das Europäische
Parlament zu einem Diskussionsprozess
hierzu eingeladen man könnte auch sagen
Sie dazu aufgefordert und als
Sozialdemokraten haben wir uns mit
unseren Koalitionspartnern auf eine
weitere Vorgehensweise verständigt die
Prinzipien der Bundesregierung für die
Reformdiskussion zu den EU für
sky-regeln sind ja in ihrem Antrag und
auch hier in der Debatte jetzt schon
mehrfach angesprochen worden denn es ist
in der Tat enorm wichtig gerade jetzt an
gemeinsamen Lösungen zur Stärkung und
Vertiefung des stabilitäts- und
wachstumspaktes zu arbeiten um die
europäische Stabilität in diesen
Krisenzeiten zu gewährleisten verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und dabei geht
es keineswegs darum dass irgendwie Geld
aus dem Fenster geschmissen werden soll
wie sie mit ihren Vorwürfen immer so so
ein bisschen suggerieren
sondern und da will ich gerne auch
Kanzler Olaf Scholz aus der
europaausschusssitzung am Mittwoch zu
der aus corona-gründen digital
zugeschaltet war zitieren
transformationsinvestitionen müssen auch
in diesen Zeiten möglich sein verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und damit hat
er vollkommen recht
denn Zukunftsinvestitionen die sind
nicht nur notwendig um
investitionsschulden in Zukunft Kollegin
Schäfer hat darauf hingewiesen zu
vermeiden sondern sie zahlen sich auch
aus denn sie führen ja letztlich zu
einer Stärkung unserer Volkswirtschaften
in der Zukunft und deshalb haben wir
auch im Koalitionsvertrag ganz klar
verankert dass wir die nötigen Zukunft
Investitionen gewährleisten wollen
insbesondere in Klimaschutz
Digitalisierung Bildung und Forschung
und im Ausbau und Sanierung der
notwendigen Infrastruktur auch um die
deutsche Wirtschaft zukunftsfest und
nachhaltig aufzustellen und dabei
Arbeitsplätze zu sichern verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und es ist wichtig dass es den
stabilitäts- und Wachstumspakt gibt denn
die exzessive Verschuldung eines
Mitgliedsstaates die kann natürlich auch
Auswirkungen für andere Mitgliedstaaten
mit sich bringen und damit
möglicherweise die Stabilität der
gesamten Währungsunion gefährden
Fiskalregeln sind in einem geweinen
gemeinsamen Währungsraum notwendig
genauso wichtig ist es eben aber auch
dass der stabi-pakt kein starres Gebilde
ist und dass er weiterentwickelt wird
und in diesem Sinne gehört diese hohe
Flexibilität die wir mit der
ausweichklausel eben auch nutzen gerade
zu den großen Stärken des stabilitäts-
und wachstumspakts und das hat dieses
fiskalische Regelwerk der Europäischen
Union zuletzt in der Pandemie auch
eindrucksvoll bewiesen indem es eben an
zentralen Stellen die Berücksichtigung
spezifischer Umstände erlaubt hat und
damit Möglichkeiten eröffnet hat wo es
sonst nur Stillstand gegeben hätte auf
dieser Grundlage kann man aufbauen und
die Vorschläge aus dem Prinzipien Papier
der Bundesregierung auch für die
Weiterentwicklung des stabilitäts- und
wachstumspakts nutzen mit mehr
Transparenz und Effizienz mit einer
Konkretisierung der Kriterien bei der
Anwendung der allgemeinen
ausweichklausel oder auch mit der
Herstellung einer größeren
organisatorischen Unabhängigkeit des
European fiskalboards von der
Europäischen Kommission alles Vorschläge
die man diskutieren kann die
Schuldentragfähigkeit und die Sicherung
solider öffentliche Haushalte bleiben
dabei aber wichtige Kernziele und es
braucht deshalb tatsächlich klare und
schrittweise Pläne für den Abbau von
Schulden Schuldenabbau bleibt das Ziel
aber und da ist der große Unterschied
ohne dabei die Herausforderungen von
Inflation und Krisensituationen aus dem
Blick zu verlieren verehrte Kolleginnen
und Kolle
das ist der einzige Weg wie wir sowohl
wirtschaftliche als auch politische
Stabilität innerhalb der Europäischen
Union beibehalten können und in der
aktuellen Krise ist die Stärke Europas
auch unsere Stärke verehrte Kolleginnen
und Kollegen und zwar mehr denn je
vielen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Johannes schreibt zwar das für die SPD
ausgerechnet Deutschland und Frankreich
waren die ersten Staaten die die
schuldenkriterien damals gerissen haben
und die Union möchte dass sie wieder
eingeführt werden während der Pandemie
waren die Regeln des stabilitäts- und
wachstumspakts ja ausgesetzt waren bis
zum Jahr 2024 Norbert Kleinwächter
das ist ja fein
sie fordern das regeln wieder
eingehalten werden nachdem sie von der
Union 16 Jahre lang unter Angela Merkel
wirklich jeden Norm die in politischen
nicht in den Kragen gepasst hat über
Bord geworfen haben da können Sie schon
den Saal verlassen das ist die Wahrheit
hätte sich die Union mit Angela Merkel
von Anfang an für die eine Haltung der
maastrichtkriterien ausgesprochen dann
hätten wir heute nicht die Probleme der
Inflation der Geldentwertung die wir in
der Eurozone sehen hättet ihr Union
damals unter Angela Merkel hören Sie
ruhig zu Herr märz
zum Beispiel den Atomausstieg nicht
spontan beschlossen gegen jegliche
Normen dann stünden wir heute im Winter
nicht vor diesen
energieversorgungsproblemen hätte die
Union damals unter Angela Merkel nicht
gleichzeitig Schengen Dublin das
Asylgesetz das Grundgesetz über Bord
geworfen und massenhaft
illegale migrantenimportiert dann hätten
wir auch kein Problem mit
sozialtoorismus Herr Merz und dann
hätten wir auch kein Problem mit
demokratischer Stabilität und
Zufriedenheit und Wohlstand in
ein Land und deswegen ist es wohlfalt
deswegen ist es wohlfalt dass sie das
fordern nachdem sie sogar noch vor drei
Jahren eine Ursula von der Leyen in die
EU-Kommission befördert haben eine die
jetzt die Ausbildung des physikalparks
fordert und gleichzeitig eine Christin
Lagarde an die Spitze der europäischen
Zentralbank die beide nur einen sind ein
zentrales Ziel haben auf der einen Seite
die Schuldenunion in Europa zu
ermöglichen und gleichzeitig die
Souveränität der Nationalstaaten zu
untergraben und abzugraben meine Damen
und Herren
koste es was es wolle whatever it takes
und wenn es unser Wohlstand ist
aber kommen wir doch tatsächlich zu
ihrer Kernforderung dass der
stabilitäts- und Wachstumspakt wenn wir
jetzt mal daran glauben dass er
tatsächlich eingehalten werden könnte
tatsächlich eingehalten werden soll er
schreibt zum Beispiel eine Maximalgrenze
von 60% Schuldenniveau im Verhältnis zum
Bruttoinlandsprodukt vor und wir müssen
an dieser Stelle feststellen kein an
keinem einzigen Tag in der Existenz der
Eurozone haben alle Euro-Mitgliedsländer
die Konvergenzkriterien eingehalten an
keinem einzigen Tag war das der Fall 60%
ist die aktuelle Obergrenze wir stehen
in Griechenland schon bei
189,3 Italien
152,6 die Eurozone im Schnitt bei 95,6
Prozent
italien hatte bei seinem Beitritt schon
106,36 Prozent wie wollen sie bitteschön
politisch wie auch wirtschaftlich diese
Absenkung auf 60% hinbekommen wie wollen
Sie das machen ich sage Ihnen was der
Zug ist abgefahren und er ist abgefahren
weil sie das damals ermöglicht haben
weil sie Programme wie EFSF aufgelegt
haben die einmalig sein sollten wir
jetzt selbst Generation EU und die sich
aber zu ESM verfestigt haben ich sage
Ihnen was wir brauchen den Fiskalpakt
nicht aushöhlen wir brauchen ihn auch
nicht fordern wir müssen sagen Weg aus
diesem ganzen System weg vom Euro und
muss es egal sein können ob Italien
Schulden macht hauptsache wir haben
Normen an die wir uns halten die wir
demokratisch legitimiert haben und die
für Wohlstand und Wachstum in unserem
Land sorgen und das geht nur auf
nationaler Ebene mit nationaler
Legitimation und nationaler Entscheidung
haben sie herzlichen Dank
für die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
hat nun Andreas andritsch das Wort
[Applaus]
erst richtig alles gut ich danke der
Kollegin Lötsch also der Kollege
frau Präsidentin
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
die Lage in Europa ist ernst dieser Tage
und sie ist ernst angesichts eines
gaskrieges von Wladimir Putin und Herren
und das war also aus der
Bundespressekonferenz und jetzt sind wir
hier wieder live im Plenum des Deutschen
Bundestages es geht um einen Antrag der
cdu/csu-stabilitätsunion statt Schulden
Union darin fordert die cdu/csu die
Fiskalregeln des stabilitäts- und
wachstumspraxis und des
physikalvertrages zügig wieder in Kraft
zu setzen während der Pandemie waren die
ja ausgesetzt worden und sollen erst
2024 wieder in Kraft gesetzt werden und
die Union möchte dass das schneller geht
der Redner der jetzt gerade am Pult
steht heißt Andreas audritsch von den
Bündnisgrünen und er ist der zuständige
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzender
und völlig ignorant gegenüber den Fragen
die sich in ganz Europa derzeit stellen
haben sie auf die Idee
wie kommen sie auf die Idee in einer
Zeit wie dieser die wir gerade erleben
einen Antrag zu stellen in der in dem
steht und ich zitiere das vom Krisen in
den regelmodus übergegangen werden soll
haben Sie gemerkt was um sie herum
passiert merken Sie was wir hier in
Deutschland gerade machen merken sie
dass wir gestern 200 Milliarden Euro in
den in den Pott getan haben und in die
Vollen geht weil wir einen Gaskrieg
haben soll es der ernst sein den sie
hier tatsächlich vortragen dass wir in
Deutschland in die Vollen gehen und wer
gleichzeitig sagen das Spanien das
Griechenland das Frankreich in einen
Normalmodus übergehen soll das ist von
einer Ignoranz geprägt das ist von einer
Selbstbezogenheit geprägt die nicht zu
ertragen ist was sie andauernd hier
Vortrag ist ein eine ideologische
Selbstbezogenheit die keine Lösung
bietet sie wollen zementieren was in
Europa was in Europa über Jahre falsch
gelaufen ist sie wollen zementieren dass
Sanktionen das spar-diktat im
Mittelpunkt steht und nicht das
Gestalten und sie setzen sich hier hin
oder wenn Sie hier an das Pult und
fordern jeden Tag neue Milliarden
Maßnahmen jeden Tag werden neue
fantastilliarden ins Schaufenster
gestellt von ihnen ohne jegliche
Gegenfinanzierung sie finanzieren nicht
von alledem gegen und dann gehen sie
auch noch los und sagen dass in anderen
Ländern jetzt gespart werden muss das
passt hinten und vorne nicht zusammen
das überhaupt kein Konzept und genau das
wird dazu weil sie so agieren dass sie
das dass sie Europa auseinandertreiben
es ist schlimm genug wenn sie völlig
unseriöse Politik in Deutschland machen
es ist schlimmer wenn sie gleichzeitig
versuchen Missgunst in Europa zu sehen
und das werden wir Ihnen so nicht
durchgehen lassen
sich in Krisen reinzusparen sich in
Krisen reinzusparen führt am Ende zur
höheren Schuldenquoten wir haben das
nach der Finanzkrise 2008 so oft gesehen
das ist so oft diskutiert worden und ich
hätte gehofft dass sie das irgendwann
mal wahrnehmen in der Debatte dass sie
mal Zeitungen lesen dass sie sich mal
angucken was da passiert tun sie leider
nicht wenn wir jetzt nicht in ganz
Europa in Erneuerbare Energien
investieren wissen Sie was dann passiert
dann kommen wir nie weg von den fossilen
Energien von Putin dann werden wir nie
an den Punkt kommen dass wir souveräner
werden dann werden wir nie an den Punkt
kommen dass wir klimaneutraler werden
dann werden wir nie an den Punkt kommen
dass wir auch die Inflation in den Griff
kriegen sie haben 16 Jahre lang dafür
gesorgt dass Putin jetzt so eine große
Macht hat das auszulösen was jetzt im
Moment in Europa los ist und wenn wir
das Befolgen was sie sagen dann wird das
uns auch in den nächsten Jahren weiter
drohen sie haben nichts gelernt und das
zeigen sie genau mit dem Antrag den Sie
hier heute vorlegen
wir stehen
schön dass sie sich so aufregen dann
merkt man dass sie es bewegt und dass
sie sich damit auseinandersetzen
wir stehen vor einer sehr konkreten
Debatte wir stehen von der sehr
konkreten Debatte über den stabilitäts-
und Wachstumspakt und ja es ist richtig
wir brauchen Reformen das ist klar das
Regelwerk muss einfacher werden es muss
verschlankt werden dass es völlig klar
wir brauchen mehr Transparenz wir
brauchen mehr Nachvollziehbarkeit die
einen 20 Regel zum Beispiel so stark
dass sie nicht funktioniert auch das
muss reformiert werden das ist völlig
klar aber wir müssen dabei einen Fokus
behalten wir müssen den Fokus behalten
dass wir nicht mit einer ideologischen
one size-fits allregelung versuchen
irgendwelche Diktate über ganz Europa zu
legen sondern dass wir uns mit den
Problemen in den Ländern
auseinandersetzen und dass wir Lösungen
finden und dass wir Investitionen
ermöglichen um dann auch aus den
Problemen herauszukommen
im Angesicht
im Angesicht der aktuellen Krisen und
dieser größten politischen Krise die
auch noch für uns wartet zu lösen der
Klimakrise müssen wir zum einen
stabilisieren dass wir jetzt durchkommen
und müssen wir zum anderen investieren
um in Zukunft nicht mehr in solche
Krisen zu kommen das ist der Weg den wir
gehen müssen das haben sie nicht
verstanden deswegen ist es gut dass wir
das tun danke Ihnen
[Applaus]
ich bitte wenn es sie nach einer Frage
oder Bemerkung drängt das noch während
der Redezeit anzuzeigen
Herr Brandner
ich muss erst einmal überhaupt nichts
und es
gibt jetzt überhaupt nicht zu verhandeln
also jede Fraktion hat auch
parlamentarische Geschäftsführer wenn
das Präsidium anderweitig beschäftigt
ist ist es möglich dass die
Parlamentarischen Geschäftsführer die
Interessen ihre Fraktionsmitglieder
vertreten und auch Frage und redewünsche
direkt anmelden so und wir fahren jetzt
weiter fort in der Debatte das Wort hat
der Kollege Florian osner für die CDU
CSU
Petra braucht gerade das Präsidium
übernommen es gab eine Fragestellung aus
der afd-fraktion das hat sie nicht
gesehen das Präsidium auch nicht und da
hat sich die AFD erregt jetzt Florian
sehr geehrte Kollege audresch also trotz
aller rhetorischer Schulungen es war
wirklich eine ein völliger blanko-beweis
an sachlichem Hintergrund und hat
wirklich überhaupt nichts überhaupt
nichts mit unserem vorgelegten Antrag zu
tun den wir heute diskutieren
um besser besser könnte es wirklich
nicht passen wir haben die Woche ja der
Nachhaltigkeit und zumindest die cduc so
Fraktion hat dieses Jahr mit Aktionen
belegt und brachte zum Beispiel
regionale Produkte aus der Heimat mit
die Ampel zeigte hier relativ wenig
Ambitionen die spiegelt sich auch
komplett wieder in der Finanzpolitik
seit Ludwig Erz Seitner ist die
finanzielle Nachhaltigkeit fest in der
DNA unsere Union verankert bei rot-Grün
ist es nicht erkennbar die Forderungen
und man heute wieder hotties heute
wieder bemerkbar allen vorrätern die
Forderungen nach Auflösung von
Schuldenbremsen und zusätzlich
Milliardensummen aus dem Bundeshaushalt
überschlagen sich ja förmlich im
täglichen Rhythmus das ist der
fundamentale Unterschied zwischen einer
soliden Haushalts und Finanzpolitik von
CD und CSU und eine rot-grünen Schuldner
und Umverteilungspolitik
ein aufweichender der
Schuldenbremse werden wir uns als Union
entschlossen in Gegenständen und die
Einhaltung ist auch kein bloßer
Selbstzweck wir uns immer wieder
vorgeworfen wurde oder ein sogenannter
Fetisch wie es auch einmal bezeichnet
wurde sondern eine Frage der
Glaubwürdigkeit solange nicht alle
verzichtbaren Ausgaben in der jetzigen
Krisensituation auf den Prüfstand
gestellt werden solange verbietet es
sich über neue exorbitante Schulden zu
sprechen auch der neue doppelwumms vom
Bundeskanzler Scholz gestern dürfte sehr
teuer werden 200 Milliarden Euro nur für
den Gaspreis das sind 2.500 Euro
2.500 Euro neue Schulden für jeden
Bundesbürger und sogar 13.000 Euro neue
Schulden für jeden netto-steuerzahler
das einfach Wahnsinn solide Haushalte
bedeutende
hingegengenerationengerechtigkeit
Handlungsspielräume in der Zukunft und
nachhaltiges Wirtschaftswachstum
finanzielle Nachhaltigkeit darf aber
jedoch nicht nur für Deutschland gelten
sondern natürlich auch für die gesamte
Europäische Union derzeit ist der
europäische stabilitäts- und
Wachstumspakt bis Ende 23 aus der Kraft
gesetzt und zur Sache zurückzukehren
vorwiegen Corona jetzt wegen dem Krieg
in der Ukraine dies darf jedoch kein
Dauerzustand bleiben deshalb finden in
der EU Überlegungen statt wie der Pakt
reformiert werden kann Deutschland kommt
in dieser Reformdebatte dabei eine
Schlüsselrolle zu als größte
Volkswirtschaft Europas haben wir hier
eine Vorbildfunktion einzunehmen eine
Positionierung der Ampel wie sie erst im
August erfolgt ist war er da längst
längst überfällig
allerdings sind diese Vorschläge
zweifelhaft und machen ohne ihn ein
kompliziertes Regelwerk noch
komplizierter es so zielt die Ampel auf
eine Aufweichung der EU Fiskalregeln an
der Schuldenabbau soll aufgegeben werden
die
flexibilitätsklauseln für Investitionen
und damit auch die Ausnahme Tatbestände
sollen ausgeweitet werden das alles
führt nicht zu einem Mehr an Vertrauen
exakt das bräuchte aber jetzt der Euro
und die Europäische Union in der
schwierigen Zeit
als cducs zur Bundestagsfraktion sieben
ebenfalls eine dringenden Reformbedarf
entscheidend ist dabei für uns die
stabilitäts-regeln zu verbessern
Neuverschuldung maximal drei Prozent des
Bruttoinlandsprodukts und der
Schuldenstand höchstens 60%. das sind
verlässliche Größen seit Theo Waigel und
auch die Zielsetzung eines verbindlichen
Schuldenabbaus muss weiterhin Bestand
haben zum Beispiel durch eine Glättung
des ababfahrts ganz konkret darüber
hinaus erteilen wir allen Formen zur
Pläne dafür gemeinschaftung der Schulden
in die Uni klare Absage das gilt vor
allem in Zeiten der Inflation ich komme
zum Schluss denn um abschließend
nochmals Ludwig Erhard zu zitieren die
Inflation ist eine unverzeihliche Sünde
das Vertrauen in eine stabile und
verlässliche Fiskalpolitik ist
entscheidend für Privatinvestitionen
aber auch für einen dauerhaften
Zusammenhalt in Europa deshalb ist
Montag richtig herzlichst Vergehens Gott
fürs zuhören
Florian Osna hat hier noch mal
dargestellt was die Union will
Stabilitätsunion statt Schuldenunion und
der nächste Redner kommt aus der
FDP-Fraktion ist im Haushaltsausschuss
Carsten klein
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich denke es
ist wichtig dass man vielleicht noch mal
darauf hinweisen dass die
Bundesregierung einen Vorschlag gemacht
hat zur Reform des Stabilitätspaktes und
diese Reform stellt noch mal fest dass
an dem 60% Ziel der Staatsverschuldung
und 3% Defizit nicht gerüttelt wird das
ist die zentrale Botschaft von diesem
Vorschlag
und ich möchte in die Richtung der Union
sagen das ist vielleicht für uns als
Freie Demokraten eine
Selbstverständlichkeit aber für Sie
sicher nicht wenn man sich die
Verhandlungsstrategien der von ihnen
geführten Bundesregierung in den letzten
Jahren auf europäischer Ebene angeschaut
hat haben sie von Mal zu Mal unsere
Kriterien für solide Staatsfinanzierung
gebrochen auf europäischer Ebene den
sind sie eben nicht nachgekommen
und deshalb ist es wahrscheinlich für
die ein oder anderen europäischen
Partner fast schon eine Überraschung
gewesen
für uns nicht für die europäischen
Partner und wahrscheinlich auch für die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Union das
die Bundesregierung überhaupt einen
Vorschlag unterbreitet hat Deutschland
ist doch als reformmotor in Europa in
den letzten Jahren Unterführung von
Angela Merkel ausgefallen jede Debatte
zu Reformen in Europa wo Vorschläge zum
Beispiel aus Frankreich gekommen sind
war doch Stille aus dem Kanzleramt und
deshalb finde ich sollten Sie das in
ihrem Antrag mal lobend erwähnen bevor
Sie hier den Schulmeister spielen
und dann möchte ich darauf hinweisen
dass es nicht nur wichtig ist das
richtige zusammenlegen Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Union sondern das was auch
an der richtigen Stelle tun muss und die
richtige Stelle wäre gewesen als next
generation EU verhandelt worden ist dass
man auch gleichzeitig Eckpunkte für die
Reform des Stabilitätspakt damals
verhandelt hätte damals als die
Bundesrepublik etwas in die Waagschale
gelegt hat als wir Garantien gegeben
haben für die Wiederaufbau vor in Europa
hätten wir diese Eckpunkte verhandeln
müssen Fehlanzeige der Union wir haben
sie geschlafen für die Interessen des
Steuerzahlers liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und die von ihnen so sehr zitierten
Vertreter der Union Theo Waigel der
hätte in dieser Situation auch
eingefordert dass der wachstums- und
Stabilitätspakt eingehalten wird wo war
denn die deutsche Bundesregierung in den
Jahren zwischen der Finanzkrise und der
corona-krise als zwar in Deutschland die
Schulden runtergefahren worden sind
prozentual zum BIP aber eben nicht in
Europa wo war denn die deutsche
Bundesregierung und die Kanzlerin da war
Stillschweigen im Kanzleramt und deshalb
brauchen wir jetzt keine
schlaumeierischen Empfehlungen von
Seiten der Unionsfraktion liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich will noch einmal festhalten der
Blick nach Großbritannien der Blick in
die Vereinigten Staaten zeigt was
expansive Fiskalpolitik auslösen kann
enorm hohe Inflationszahlen steigende
Renditen damit Zinskosten für den Staat
das alles zeigt doch dass wir eben gut
beraten sind nicht nur in Deutschland
die Schuldenbremse einzuhalten wie diese
Bundesregierung sich vorgenommen hat
sondern auch an den Kriterien der
Stabilitätspakt 3% und 60 Prozent
festzuhalten das ist die Basis das ist
das Fundament für eine handlungsfähige
Europäische Union
und deshalb liebe Kollegin lösch auch an
Ihrer Adresse noch mal deutlich
formuliert für uns sind Freiheit
Verantwortung und Solidarität
Grundpfeiler der Europäischen Union und
unseres Gemeinwesens aber wer
solidarisch sein will der braucht einen
handlungsfähigen Staat einen
handlungsfähigen Staat gibt es aber nur
wenn man stabile und solide
Staatsfinanzen hat wenn man die
schuldenbremsung in Stabilitätspakt
einhält und deshalb ist es die
Grundvoraussetzung für Solidarität eben
auch eine solide Finanzpolitik zuurch zu
führen und nicht eine auseinanderdriften
dieser beiden Ziele
und deshalb will ich noch mal in den
Mittelpunkt am Ende stellen wer die
daueraufgaben eines Staates finanzieren
will soziale Sicherung äußere Sicherheit
Bildungschancen
Klimaschutz Klimaschutz und
Digitalisierung der muss sich an solide
Staatsfinanzen und ein Einhaltung der
schuldenbremsung des Stabilitätspakt des
halten dazu hat die Bundesregierung gute
Vorschläge gemacht auf europäischer
Ebene und die finden auch uns
Unterstützung vielen Dank
[Applaus]
bei ihren Meister für die CDU
CSU-Fraktion und Michael Meister ist der
letzte Redner in dieser Debatte er sitzt
im Finanzausschuss für die Union liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir haben seit
1999 eine gemeinsame Währung den Euro
wir haben seit 1999 eine gemeinsame
Geldpolitik aber wir haben keine
gemeinsame Finanz- und
Wirtschaftspolitik und deshalb ist es
dringend notwendig bei 27 verschiedenen
Finanz- und Wirtschaftspolitiken das ist
dafür einen Rahmen gibt um die
zusammenzuhalten und dafür brauchen wir
den stabilitäts- und Wachstumspakt in
Europa
ein solches Experiment mit einer Währung
ohne gemeinsame Finanz- und
Wirtschaftspolitik gibt sonst nirgendwo
auf der Welt und das zeigt die zentrale
Bedeutung des Themas was wir hier
diskutieren und deshalb liebe Frau
Hagedorn ist das was wir heute hier
machen nicht aus der Zeit gefallen
die Bundesregierung hat einen Vorschlag
gemacht die EU-Kommission kündigt für
nächsten Monat einen Vorschlag an und
wer muss denn über diese Frage
diskutieren dieser Deutsche Bundestag
und wir haben die Debatte hierher geholt
und das nicht aus der Zeit gefallen
sondern es dringend notwendig
wir haben zehn Prozent Inflationen in
diesem Land seit gestern
seit 70 Jahren nicht mehr in der
Dimension
und der stabilitäts- und Wachstumspakt
soll dafür sorgen dass die Finanzpolitik
nicht zu expansiv ausfällt und was
machen wir aktuell wir machen eine
expansive Finanzpolitik wie wir sie auf
dieser Welt noch nicht hatten in Europa
500 Milliarden Euro hat diese Koalition
in einem Jahr an neuen Schulden
ausgewiesen 500 Milliarden Euro
die Finanzminister der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland vor Herrn Lindner haben es
auf rund 1.200 gebracht machen Sie sich
das mal klar was das bedeutet 500
Milliarden Euro wir sind ein schlechtes
Vorbild für Europa und deshalb brauchen
wir in dieser Debatte es hören Sie doch
mal auf zu schreien und hören zu ich
habe die ganze Zeit auch intensiv
zugehört deshalb brauchen wir in dieser
Debatte dringend Orientierung
und ich sie als Bundesregierung und als
koalitionsfraktion haben bisher diese
Orientierung vermissen lassen wir sehen
Reformbedarf an diesem stabilitäts- und
Wachstumspakt aus unserer Sicht dieser
zu komplex und deshalb muss Komplexität
rausgenommen werden die Bindungswirkung
der Regeln ist offensichtlich nicht
stark genug wir geben uns Regeln und
halten uns nicht daran also muss die
bindungswerken gestärkt werden und der
dritte Punkt ist es muss einen
Schiedsrichter auf dem Platz geben der
für die Durchsetzung der Regeln sagt und
das ist nicht geschehen und daran haben
sie aber auch eine massive Verantwortung
der erste der dafür gesorgt hat dass das
nicht geschieht war der Bundeskanzler
Gerhard Schröder der damals diesen Pakt
übertreten hat und nicht eingehalten hat
da haben unser schlechtes Vorbild
begonnen und darunter leiden wir noch
heute meine Damen und Herren
was wir nicht mitmachen werden als Union
ist es herausrechnen einzelner
Positionen aus der Ausgabenseite das
kann nicht sein weil da wird niemand ein
Ende finden und niemand wird eine klare
Definition finden und jetzt
argumentieren sie Name müsse doch
investieren schauen Sie doch mal ihren
eigenen Bundeshaushalt an der leidet
doch nicht unter der Tatsache dass zu
viel investiert würde der leidet
darunter dass zu viel konservativ
ausgegeben wird und wenn sie schon für
Investitionen werben dann tun sie es
doch in ihrem Haushalt und setzen den
Schwerpunkt bei Investitionen und nicht
beim Konsum das ist das Problem an der
Stelle
wir sind klar gegen eine
Individualisierung des Regelwerks es
kann nichts bringen wenn jedes Land
eigene Regeln hat
und wir sind dafür dass wir das
Primärrecht nicht ändern darüber
herrscht große Einigkeit die drei
Prozent die 60% bleiben stehen dazu
haben wir eine klare Position und liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen zum Abschluss
wir sind in Deutschland nicht der
Schulmeister aber wir sind als größter
Volkswirtschaft das Vorbild Europas und
deshalb sollten wir uns auch vorbildlich
verhalten vielen Dank
ich schließe die Aussprache wir kommen
zur Abstimmung über den Antrag der
Fraktion der cdu/csu auf Drucksache
3691 mit dem Titel
Stabilitätsunion statt Schuldenunion
stabilitäts- und Wachstumspakt festigen
fiskalpolitische Disziplin in Europa
sichern die Fraktion der cdu/csu hat
namentliche Abstimmung verlangt die
Abstimmung erfolgt wieder in der
westlobby zur Abgabe ihrer Stimme haben
sie 20 Minuten Zeit ich sehe die
Schriftführerin und Schriftführer haben
die vorgesehenen Plätze eingenommen
ich eröffne die namentliche Abstimmung
über den Antrag der Fraktion der CDU CSU
die
abstimmungsurnen werden um 11 Uhr 54
geschlossen das bevorstehende Ende der
namentlichen Abstimmung wird Ihnen
rechtzeitig bekannt gegeben
ich bitte diejenigen die jetzt zur
Abstimmung eilen bitte
die Wege frei zu machen diejenigen die
an der nächsten Debatte teilnehmen
können und wollen Platz zu nehmen
und ja meine Damen und Herren sie haben
es gehört also über den Antrag der
co-csu wird jetzt namentlich abgestimmt
seit corona-zeiten geht das ja etwas
nahtloser als es früher der Fall war da
wurden die Ohren nämlich aufgebaut im
Plenarsaal und dann entstand immer eine
längliche Pause das ist hier nicht der
Fall die Urnen sind ja seit gut zwei
Jahren draußen auf dem Flur aufgebaut
und dort können jetzt die Abgeordneten
und müssen in den nächsten 20 Minuten
ihre stimmkärtchen einwerfen während
hier der Vorteil für den Ablauf hier im
Plenarsaal hier kann es nämlich gleich
weitergehen mit dem nächsten Punkt und
das ist auch ein ganz interessanter
Punkt Änderung des
energie-sicherheitsgesetzes von den
Fraktionen SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und
FDP eingebracht Entwurfs einen zweiten
Gesetzes zur Änderung des
energiesicherungsgesetzes und anderer
energiewirtschaftlicher Vorschriften die
Novelle des Gesetzes das in seiner
aktuellen Fassung seit der Ölkrise 1975
bestehen die dazu die Krisenvorsorge zu
stärken und im das falsch schnell
handlungsfähig zu sein unter anderem
wird darin gefordert den biogasdeckel
wegzunehmen die das repowering-verbot
also die Modernisierung für Solarparks
das ab 2023 fällig war wegzunehmen so
dass Solarparks künftig ihre Leistung
steigern können und einige andere Punkte
aber darum geht es hier in diesem Antrag
der jetzt hier als nächstes
auf dem planschirm und es gibt noch
einen schließ
Entschließungsantrag der cdu/cs oder zu
der Kombi aber später zu von 39 Minuten
vereinbart
ich bitte jetzt noch einmal Platz zu
nehmen
ja und die die hier sitzen sind für das
Thema eingeteilt müssen aber nicht
vergessen noch abzustimmen zwischendurch
wird der ein oder andere Mal aufstehen
und rausgehen weit ist es ja nicht also
die erste Rednerin hier sind die neuen
Debatten Punkte das
der nennt sich Moment Änderung der
energiesicherheitsgesetzes Julia
Verlinden stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Bündnisgrünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren ich möchte vier
Punkte machen zum einen möchte ich daran
erinnern dass wir einen riesigen Booster
ein Energiepaket im Sommer verabschiedet
haben hier gemeinsam im Juli und damit
die Weichen gestellt haben für einen
massiven schnelleren Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien und dass das
dringend notwendig ist das sehen wir
auch wieder in den Debatten der letzten
Wochen und Monate wie wichtig das ist
dass wir uns unabhängig machen von den
fossilen Rohstoffimporten und wie
wertvoll es ist dass wir eben diese
günstige Energieform hier massiv
ausbauen
und jetzt sind die Kommunen dran sind
die Länder dran
insbesondere in Bayern merken wir wie
die Debatte hochkocht darüber wo ist
denn oder ist denn genug Strom da wird
denn genug Strom auch durch die
Leitungen transportiert und so weiter
und so fort und ich glaube viele fangen
an nachzudenken ob das was in den
letzten Jahren für eine Position
vertreten haben wirklich die richtige
war und jetzt geht es darum zusätzlich
die bereits bestehenden Erneuerbaren
energienanlagen zu nutzen um diese
günstige Energieform noch weiter quasi
aus den bestehenden Anlagen rauszuholen
denn es gab in der Vergangenheit
politische Fehlentscheidungen die Deckel
eingezogen haben die gesagt haben okay
du darfst zwar eine Solaranlage auf dein
Dach setzen aber sie darf nicht 100%
Leistung ins Netz einspeisen und das war
wirklich eine Absurdität und da räumen
wir jetzt vernünftig auf
der zweite der dritte Punkt den ich
machen möchte ist dass wir
selbstverständlich noch viel viel mehr
auch tun werden und bereits dabei sind
auch in den Bereich Energie sparen
Energieeffizienz zu investieren vieles
können natürlich die Menschen jetzt
bereits selber tun und wir haben wieder
den
aktiven Aufruf auch von der
Bundesnetzagentur in den letzten Tagen
gehört wie wichtig das ist das
Unternehmen die das bereits tun
fortsetzen aber auch Privatpersonen
endlich noch viel mehr Energie sparen
damit wir gut über diesen Winter kommen
die Gasspeicher sind dankenswerterweise
voll durch das Gute Management unserer
Regierung auch und durch der durch die
Bundesnetzagentur aber es muss eben noch
mehr getan werden auch beim
Energiesparen das nützt auch allen in
Ihrem Geldbeutel
und was wir nicht vergessen dürfen ist
es müssen auch Investitionen fließen in
moderne Heizungen in neue Technik und da
haben wir glücklicherweise auch gute
Förderprogramme auf die zurückgegriffen
werden kann
und den vierten und letzten Punkt den
ich machen möchte angesichts des
energiesicherungsgesetzes ist dass ich
danke sagen möchte danke auch an die
Oppositionsfraktion der Linken und der
Union weil sie auch mit dazu beigetragen
haben dass wir hier ein sehr zügiges
Verfahren gehabt haben im Bundestag wir
haben zu sehr unkonventionellen Zeiten
eine Sachverständigen Anhörung um 7 Uhr
morgens im Ausschuss gehabt es ist eine
Herausforderung im Augenblick auch für
dieses Parlament für die
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter in den
Ausschüssen in den Abgeordnetenbüros in
den Fraktionen auch für die
Sachverständigen ist das keine normale
Uhrzeit und ich glaube dass wir damit
zeigen als Parlament dass wir in dieser
Krise handlungsfähig sind vielen Dank
auf Julia Verlinden antwortet jetzt
Alexander Dobrindt der landesgruppenchef
der CSU
landesgruppenchef der CSU der CSU
Stellvertreter der cdu/csu als
Fraktionschef und wenn die CSU nicht in
einer Fraktionsgemeinschaft wäre wäre
Alexander Dober und der
Fraktionsvorsitzende der CSU
der Energiemangel bedroht unsere
Wirtschaft explodierende Energiepreise
bedrohen den sozialen Frieden wir teilen
die Einschätzung des
Bundesfinanzministers dass wir eine
energiekrieg erleben wir teilen übrigens
auch die Einschätzung des Bundeskanzlers
das ist eine große kraftanstegung
braucht aber nicht erst seit gestern
meine Damen und Herren wir unterstützen
notwendige Maßnahmen wenn sie vertrauen
Sicherheit und wirtschaftliche
Stabilität bieten aber es reicht
schlichtweg nicht alleine aus
Energiepolitik durch Finanzpolitik
ersetzen zu wollen meine Damen und
Herren
es ist notwendig zu entscheiden mit wie
viel Geld der Staat ist bereit in die
Krise einzuspringen aber es ist doch
noch wichtiger zu erfahren bei wem
dieses Geld ankommt das haben sie
gestern leider versäumt Haushalte
Mittelstand Wirtschaft sie wissen nicht
was ankommt sie haben keinen doppelten
Bund verspürt sondern ein doppeltes
Fragezeichen aufgestellt
sie machen eine Politik der großen
Zahlen 200 Milliarden zugegebenermaßen
das ist erstmal
beeindruckend sie können leider nicht
erläutern wie diese Zahl sich
zusammensetzt das schafft neue
Unsicherheiten wir unterstützen Sie
dabei eine gaspreisbremse einzuführen
wir haben sie vom Monaten schon dazu
aufgefordert dieses Instrument zu nutzen
sie haben es lange Zeit nicht für
notwendig erachtet sie wollen jetzt
einen bürgerbasispreis einführen wir
haben Ihnen das vorgeschlagen aber sie
sagen nicht welche Preissenkung bei den
Haushalten ankommen sollen jeden Tag
bekommen die Haushalte aktuell
Vorauszahlungsbescheide die Gaskunden
kriegen Bescheide geschickt wo
preissteiger von drei vier fünf dem drei
vier fünffachen der bisherigen Zahlungen
drauf stehen diese Menschen brauchen
doch endlich Klarheit was auf sie
zukommt und jetzt verweisen Sie auf eine
Kommission die Ende nächsten Monats
irgendwelche Ergebnisse präsentieren
sollen sie Zäunen das Pferd von hinten
auf sagen sie den Menschen wie sie
entlasten wollen da wissen wir es was
kostet und nicht umgekehrt meine Damen
und Herren
aber vielleicht fällt Ihnen ja die
Reihenfolge deswegen so schwer weil sie
seit Monaten einen toten Gaul geritten
haben sie feiern sicher hier den ganzen
Vormittag schon für den Stopp der
gasumlage Verzeihung meine Damen und
Herren aber Herr Habeck ist nicht der
Erlöser sondern der Erschaffer der
gasumlage das ist doch die Wahrheit
sie haben die gasumlage an die Wand
gefahren als wir sie aufgefordert haben
übrigens hier im Deutschen Bundestag
mehrmals diese gasumlage zu stoppen da
hat der Bundesminister Harbeck uns in
der letzten Woche noch im Deutschen
Bundestag als Opposition beschimpft der
hat uns als die muss weg
Opposition bezeichnet heute schaffen Sie
die gasumlage ab offensichtlich sind sie
die muss weg Koalition und da sollte der
USB Minister sitzen meine Damen und
Herren
Kollege Dobrindt
ich habe die Uhr angehalten gestatten
Sie eine Frage oder Bemerkung aus der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
wir teilen das Schicksal in
Bundesländern zu leben wo es mit dem
Windkraft Ausbau überhaupt nicht
vorangeht
wir haben
dann kann ich ihn nicht ersparen die
Ergänzung wir haben es in Chemnitz
geschafft mit Unterstützung von VW
Sachsen ein Beschluss zu fassen der
trotz schwierigster
Mehrheitsverhältnisse für mehr
Windenergie selbst in der Stadt spricht
wenn Sie das albern sehen tut mir das
wirklich leid das ist
industrieschädigend was sie hier tun
Herr Dobrindt eine konkrete Frage wann
ging in ihrem Wahlkreis das letzte
Windrad ans Netz dankeschön
sehr geehrte Kollege herzlichen Dank für
Ihre Frage ich will auch eine Antwort
der Bundesregierung verweisen auf eine
aktuelle Antwort der Bundesregierung aus
diesem Monat in dieser Antwort teilt das
Bundesministerium für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz mit an der Spitze der
erneuerbaren Energien aller Bundesländer
steht das Bundesland Freistaat Bayern
erste Feststellung
zweite Feststellung aus dem
Bundesministerium für Wirtschaft und
Klimaschutz bei den einzelnen
Technologien Biomasse steht an erster
Stelle Bayern Solarenergie steht an
erster Stelle Bayern Geothermie steht an
erster Stelle Bayern Wasserkraft steht
an erster Stelle Bayern bei der
Windkraft steht Bayern vor
Baden-Württemberg deutlich beim neuen
Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien dieses
Jahr vorne Bayern das einzige wo Bayern
wirklich nicht gut ist das ist der
Windkraft auf der See meine Damen und
Herren sonst überall
[Applaus]
Italien übrigens die Antwort des
Bundesministeriums gerne auch noch
schriftlich mit
der Bundesfinanzminister hat gestern in
der
Pressekonferenz zutreffend erklärt je
besser die Senkung der Energiepreise im
Markt stattfindet desto weniger würde
aus den 200 Milliarden Euro benötigt
werden ich stimme ihm da ausdrücklich zu
aber dazu muss man auch bereit sein dass
Angebot zu erhöhen die Kapazität bei der
Energieerzeugung auszuweiten um die
Preise zu senken um in der Sprache des
Finanzministers zu bleiben All-In bei
allen
Energieerzeugern aber was sagt der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister dazu diese
Woche wir haben nicht zu wenig Strom wir
haben nur keine Netzstabilität ja
vielleicht kann man diese Kontinuität im
Irrtum endlich mal beenden meine Damen
und Herren
so und die grüne weil sie so laut
schreien von den Grünen hier die grüne
Spitzenkandidatin in Niedersachsen hat
diese Woche erklärt
Atomstrom blockiert das Netz ja meine
Damen und Herren falls es noch nicht für
alle klar geworden ist wir haben nicht
so viel Strom im Netz sondern wir haben
zu wenig und das einzige was im Moment
das Netz blockiert das ist die
ideologische Verweigerungshaltung der
Grünen die Kernkraft um zwei Jahre zu
verlängern daran scheitert es in diesem
Land
so sehr viel Applaus der Unionsfraktion
jetzt für Alexander Dobrindt aufmerksam
dass die Zeit für die namentliche
Abstimmung in fünf Minuten zu Ende geht
sollte es noch Kollegen und Kollegen
geben die nicht die Gelegenheit hatten
die Stimme abzugeben dann sollten Sie es
tun ich habe den Einwand gehört als
nächstes hat die Kollegen Dr Nina Scheer
für die SPD-Fraktion das Wort Nina
Scheer ist die Sprecherin für
Klimaschutz und Energie und die Tochter
von Hermann dem ehemaligen Alternativen
Nobelpreisträger der ja schon verstorben
ist
ich finde es schon erschreckend wie aus
den Reihen von cdu/csu mit tosendem
Beifall überdeckt werden soll das in
Land Bayern und auch unter der
leitlinienpolitik von cdu/csu eine
rückwärtsgewandte Energiepolitik gemacht
wurde eine rückwärtsgewandte
Energiepolitik und wir als SPD-Fraktion
wirklich alle Mühe hatten wenigstens
kleine Schritte zu erkämpfen in der
Frage die Fehlstellung wieder rückgängig
zu machen und da hilft es auch nicht
wenn sie auf kleine Fehlstellungen in
einzelnen Bundesländern jetzt Reiskörner
suchend um die um die in der in ihrer
Rede Vorgehen sie überdecken damit und
Täuschen damit darüber hinweg dass in
Bayern systematisch aber wirklich
systematisch die Energiewende
ausgebremst wird schon seit Jahren
die Frage der gasumlage ist ebenfalls
ein Tagesordnungspunkt tatsächlich kurz
darauf eingehen wir haben jetzt eine
Einigung die ist jetzt auch zügig
erfolgt nach einem langen Ringen um die
große Aufgabe die damit in Rede steht
wenn Gas und auch Energie insgesamt
aufgrund der fossilen energiepreiskrise
über die letzten Monate verschärft zum
Problem geworden ist und da ist es auch
kein Spaziergang so etwas so zu
organisieren dass es rechtssicher
Bestand hat insofern danke ich auch in
Richtung Bundesregierung das nun ein Weg
gefunden wurde der uns diesen
rechtssicheren Weg eröffnet es ist ein
stabiles Volumen was wir jetzt an die
Hand bekommen damit tatsächlich
Energiesicherheit auch preislich
gewährleistet werden kann in diesem
Sinne haben wir einen gemeinsamen Weg
jetzt nun gefunden und da danke ich und
bin auch frohenmut dass wir jetzt eine
Wende in der Situation hinbekommen dass
Energie auch verlässlich wieder
verfügbar und bezahlbar über die
nächsten Monate sein wird zumindest in
dem Rahmen in dem das zu sicherungsfähig
ist es ist natürlich zu betonen dass wir
alle gehalten sind weiterhin so viel wie
eine irgendwie geht einzusparen der
zweite top der zweite Tagesordnungspunkt
der beim dieser Plenardebatte heute aber
mit dem Top zusammengefasst ist ist das
viel wesentlichere nämlich unsere Option
unsere Möglichkeit die wir uns hiermit
noch mal verstärkt geben mit den
Änderungen am energiesicherungsgesetz
ein mit dem erneuerbaren Energien
Booster mit einer verstärkten
auslastungsmöglichkeit für erneuerbare
Energien den Umstieg auf erneuerbare
Energien die wir dringend brauchen um
der fossilen energiepreiskrise zu
entkommen um diesen Ausbau um diesen
Umstieg auf erneuerbare und die
Auslastung der Erneuerbaren noch
verstärkt hinzubekommen
hier rum muss es jetzt verstärkt geben
weil natürlich alle Energie die wir noch
mehr gewinnen können über die nächsten
Monate auch schon mit bestehenden
Anlagen Goldwert sind und dazu gehört
etwas dass wir vereinfachtes Repowering
machen das bei Veränderungen der Anlagen
nicht extra Genehmigungen eingeholt
werden müssen dazu gehört dass man
nachtabsenkungen für windenergietemporär
aussetzt weil dadurch einfach enorme
Potenziale verloren geht dazu gehört
auch dass wir sonder in den
Ausschreibungen die für Photovoltaik
vorgenommen werden dass wir da die Höhen
die Mengen erhöhen damit einfach noch
mehr ausgeschrieben werden kann und dazu
gehört auch und da möchte ich noch mal
ein ganz dickes Dankeschön auch an
unsere bauministerin Clara Gallwitz
aussprechen die einen Teil ihrer Novelle
aus dem Herbst jetzt vorgezogen uns zur
Verfügung gestellt hat dass wir jetzt
auch bei der Bioenergie enorme
Potenziale mit bestehenden Anlagen Herr
noch auskosten können durch mehr Stoffe
die da eingesetzt werden können also die
die Mengen werden erhöht die Mengen der
einsetzbaren Stoffe werden erhöht die
Norm Kubikmeter Grenze wird temporär
ausgesetzt und zwar bis in
einschließlich 24 und das ist ein
enormes Potenzial was wir dadurch
nochmal ergänzt bekommen herzlichen Dank
an Klara Gallwitz an dieser Stelle
nochmal und in diesem Sinne wir sind auf
einem guten Weg mit einem kräftigen
energiebooster mit dieser
energiesicherungsgesetze Welle vielen
Dank
ich mache darauf aufmerksam dass ich
nach dem nächsten Redebeitrag die
namentliche Abstimmung schließe Kollegin
Scheer sie können das ganz in Ruhe
machen nicht dass es da noch
und Frage aber auch noch einmal ist sind
noch weitere Mitglieder des Hauses
anwesend die noch nicht die Gelegenheit
hatten ihre Stimme in der namentlichen
Abstimmung abzugeben dann haben sie
nämlich Abstimmung läuft jetzt noch vier
Minuten so lange hat nämlich Mark
Bernhard von der AFD als nächster Redner
das Wort und es geht in dieser
Abstimmung um einen Antrag der cdu/csu
der hier vorhin beraten wurde für
skalpolitische Disziplin in Europa von
der Union namentlich gewünscht in vier
Minuten ist Schluss Marc Bernhard
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
als die Reisegruppe merkte dass sie sich
verlaufen hatte erhöhte sie das Tempo
genauso kommt mir der Aktionismus der
Bundesregierung vor wenn man merkt dass
man auf dem falschen Weg ist nützt es
nichts die Geschwindigkeit zu erhöhen
man kann Industrieland eben nicht mit
Sonne und Wind allein betreiben
das hat jeder in diesem Land verstanden
nur ganz offensichtlich die
Bundesregierung nicht
obwohl angeblich jede Kilowattstunde
zählt geht es in dem heute vorliegenden
Gesetzentwurf einzig und allein darum
instabile Energien weiter auszubauen und
in keinster Weise darum die Menschen
unbeschadet über diesen und den nächsten
Winter zu bringen sondern einzig und
allein darum Deutschland mit
solar-industrieanlagen zuzupflastern
wo aber die Energie herkommt wenn es
nach diesem kein Wind weht und vor allem
wie die Menschen die Energiekosten
bezahlen sollen darauf gibt es von ihnen
keine Antwort seit Beginn des Jahres
haben sich die Gaspreise mindestens
verdreifacht die Strompreise verdoppelt
die Lebensmittelpreise extrem erhöht und
wir haben eine Inflationsrate von über
10%. das gelte Bürger wird immer weniger
wert und diese Regierung verdient sich
durch diese Preisexplosion und die
dadurch immer weiter steigenden
Mehrwertsteuereinnahmen am Leid der
Menschen dumm und dusselig
und jetzt und jetzt wollen sie uns doch
tatsächlich vorgaukeln sie würden die
Menschen mit ihrer Mehrwertsteuersenkung
für Gas von 19 auf 7% entlasten
wenn Sie bisher für Gas
119 Euro im Monat bezahlt haben also 100
Euro fürs Gas plus 19 Euro für die
Mehrwertsteuer dann müssten sie
theoretisch nach der Steuersenkung auf
7% nur noch 107 Euro bezahlen
das ist der Gaspreis aber verdreifacht
hat müssen die Menschen zukünftig für
die gleiche Menge Gas
300 Euro plus 21 Euro Mehrwertsteuer
trotzdem geringeren Steuersatz bezahlen
wo ist hier also bitte die Entlastung
und für und für die Sicherung der
Millionen gefährdeten Arbeitsplätze
bringt diese Regelung ja sowieso
überhaupt gar nichts so dass die
Abwanderung von Arbeitsplätzen ins
Ausland
unbebremst weitergeht
das bisherige energiesicherungsgesetz
hat den Menschen kein offensichtlich
keine Sicherheit gebracht und die hier
debattierte Novelle geht in die gleiche
Richtung und verstärkt damit alle Fehler
das ist so als ob man einem Ertrinkenden
einen defekten Rettungsring zugeworfen
hat und ihm jetzt zur finalen Rettung
den nächsten defektenring hinterher
wirft wenn es ihnen tatsächlich darum
geht die Versorgung der Menschen mit
bezahlbarer Energie sicherzustellen
warum nutzen Sie da nicht unsere eigenen
Gasvorkommen die russische skas für
viele Jahrzehnte vollständig ersetzen
können warum geben sie den saubersten
Kohlekraftwerken der Welt keine Laufzeit
Garantie warum schalten Sie unsere Kürze
drei kürzlich abgestellten
Kernkraftwerke nicht wieder ein sondern
hoffen auf Stromlieferungen aus
ukrainischen und französischen
Atomkraftwerken und vor allem
warum lassen sie dann nur zwei der drei
sichersten Kernkraftwerke der Welt
weiterlaufen können Sie es nicht oder
wollen Sie es einfach nicht
die Zeit für die namentliche Abstimmung
ist nun vorbei gleichwohl stelle ich
noch einmal die Frage ist noch ein
Mitglied des Hauses anwesend welches
seine Stimme nicht abgegeben hat
das ist nicht der Fall ich schließe die
Abstimmung und bitte die Schriftführerin
und Schriftführer mit der Auszählung zu
beginnen das Ergebnis der Abstimmung
wird Ihnen später bekannt gegeben
wir fahren in der Debatte vor das Wort
hat der Kollege Michael Kruse für die
FDP-Fraktion Michael Kruse ist der
energiepolitische Sprecher der FDP
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
lieben Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
haben in dieser Woche sehr viel über
Energiepolitik gesprochen in diesem Haus
kein Wunder ist ein wichtiges Thema wir
haben in den Reden sehr wenig Zeit
darauf verwendet die Frage zu besprechen
die mir die meisten Menschen in
persönlichen Gesprächen stellen nämlich
was tut ihr denn jetzt eigentlich ich
habe viele Reden aus der Opposition
gehört dazu wer die Verantwortung trägt
ehrlicherweise auch aus den
Regierungsfraktionen wahlweise sind es
die Kanzlerin und die letzten 16 Jahre
Politik oder aber eben die aktuelle
Regierung
ich habe das Gefühl darauf wird 90
Prozent der Zeit hier im Haus im Moment
verwendet
in den Gesprächen die ich persönlich
außerhalb dieses Hauses führe wird
darauf ungefähr zehn Prozent der Zeit
verwendet die anderen 90% widmen sich
der Fragestellung wie kommen wir jetzt
daraus und ich meine dass diese
Fragestellung eigentlich die relevantere
für uns alle hier ist denn die Menschen
haben uns ja mit einem Grund in dieses
Parlament gewählt damit wir Ihre
Probleme lösen und deswegen meine ich
dass wir auch in dieser Debatte das in
den Mittelpunkt stellen sollten viele
Menschen sagen tut doch jetzt alles was
notwendig ist und das ist genau der
Grund warum wir in diesem Jahr zum
dritten Mal an das
energiesicherungsgesetz von 1975
herangehen wir heben jetzt den Biomasse
Deckel und ich bin der Union dankbar
dass sie an diesem Punkt ja auch darauf
hingewiesen hat wie notwendig das ist
aber hier leider noch keine Worte dazu
gefunden hat dass wir es ja jetzt auch
tun und das ist eine sehr wichtige
Maßnahme ist wir geben eine Garantie
dafür dass die Kohlekraftwerke bis 2024
ans Netz zurückkehren weil wir wissen
dass wir das brauchen obwohl niemand in
diesem Haus nicht mal die Opposition
dafür
Wahlkampf gemacht hat im letzten Jahr
wir sorgen dafür dass in kritischen
Phasen einer gasmangellage auch mehr
Windenergie zur Verfügung steht weil wir
sicher sind dass die Abwägung vieler
Menschen in diesem Land lautet
bevor wir in einem mangelage geraten
sind wir bereit auch weitere
Einschränkungen zu akzeptieren und ja
auch der dem Thema Verlängerung der
Kernenergie widmet sich diese Koalition
und ich glaube schon das ist Ausdruck
großen Verantwortungsbewusstsein weil
alle sich völlig im Klaren sind welche
hohen Hürden es gibt welche hohen
Sicherheitsauflagen hier auch zu
erzielen sind und das ist aber trotzdem
dieses Land vor einer Situation steht
dass genau eine solche Verlängerung in
den nächsten Wintern notwendig sein
könnte und wir bereiten mit allen diesen
Maßnahmen das Land darauf vor dass es
gut durch die nächsten Winter kommt und
wenn ich eine Bitte äußern dürfte dann
würde ich ehrlicherweise insbesondere
Sie Herr Kollege Dobrindt ansprechen
wollen dieses Land braucht in dieser
Situation keine Büttenreden sondern es
braucht eine verantwortungsvoll handeln
Regierung die jetzt die richtigen
Maßnahmen ergreift damit wir gut durch
den nächsten Winter kommen
und das sind ja nur mehr was sage ich
zur Kernenergie her Dobrind das kann ich
Ihnen genau sagen was ich sage wenn all
das was Sie hier ebenso ulkig
dargestellt haben wenn all das so
dermaßen zutreffen würde dann müssten
sie mir eigentlich sagen nee die
Kernkraftwerke die können ja vom letzten
Mal in Bayern da haben wir ja so viel
erneuerbaren Strom dass wir gar kein
Problem haben aber Herr Dobrind wir
stimmen ja darin überein sie können
nicht vom Netz sie können nicht vom Netz
weil sie im Süden nicht genug ausgebaut
haben und da müssen sich dann irgendwann
auch in der Kritik entscheiden entweder
Sie haben so viel ausgebaut entweder Sie
haben es alles so toll im Griff oder
aber die Kernkraftwerke müssen länger
laufen beides geht nicht und zu einer
verantwortungsvollen Oppositionsarbeit
gehört dann auch dazu sich in der Kritik
zu entscheiden und nicht wahlweise das
vorzutragen was einem gerade am besten
passt
aber wir ergreifen ja nicht nur wichtige
Maßnahmen im Bereich der Energiepolitik
sondern wir sorgen auch dafür dass wir
die Menschen in diesem Land entlasten
denn auch hier ist ja die Fragestellung
was tut ihr denn dafür dass wir uns das
noch leisten können und in dieser
Situation haben wir erstmalig übrigens
etwas was sie sich auch immer gewünscht
haben die kalte Progression voll
ausgeglichen ich erwarte Beifall an
dieser Stelle sagen Sie es doch liebe
Ampel toll dass sie das hingekriegt
haben wir hätten es Ihnen nie zugetraut
aber sie haben sie gemacht
dafür gestatten Sie eine Frage oder
Bemerkung selbstverständlich
sehr geehrte Kollege Kruse danke dass
Sie die Zwischenfrage zulassen glauben
Sie nicht dass neben dem Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren auch Grundlast gebraucht
wird und deckt sich das nicht mit
parteitagsbeschlüssen mit
parteibeschlüssen der FDP
die letzte Frage habe ich nicht
verstanden können sie sich warum deckt
sich das nicht mit parteibeschlüssen der
FDP dass man die Atomkraftwerke
unabhängig vom Ausbau der Erneuerbaren
braucht also ich denke nicht dass wir
hier jetzt die Beschlusslagen auf
einzelne Parteien miteinander
diskutieren sollten Sie haben ja sie
haben ja den Anfang meiner Rede gehört
indem ich ja darauf hingewiesen habe
dass sich die Menschen jetzt gerade eben
nicht die Frage stellt wer wann was
beschlossen hat wer wann welchen Teil an
Verantwortung und Schuld trägt sondern
dass die Menschen sich vor allem die
Frage stellt wie kommen wir denn jetzt
aus diesem Schlamassel indem wir stecken
wieder raus kann ihn natürlich zu
unserer Beschlusslage sagen dass wir im
Mai dieses Jahres oder im Ende April
dieses Jahres ein Parteitag hatten indem
wir schon darauf hingewiesen haben dass
es sein könnte dass wir diese
Kernkraftwerke als weitere Option haben
und das haben wir nicht getan weil wir
der Meinung sind dass wir das jetzt auf
alle Zeit als Technologie
weiterverfolgen wollen sondern das haben
wir getan weil es eine Konsequenz des
russischen angriffskriegs ist dass wir
jetzt alle Optionen prüfen müssen und